[Music]
if we don't control insiders this will
be
over and over to lead by an
any big fat love find common ground
to haul the spread of lies and we must
do it big fat love
find common ground to hold the spread of
life
and aid america first
america first non-fatal
we want to build a much
okay welcome to the line with a crowder
last debate live stream
we're gonna have our drinking game rules
coming up and we're gonna have senator
ted cruz but first
we're here to pre-game with the man with
the plan to die himself
the godfather the man who in the
neighborhood kisses all the girls on his
job who want to be
with donald trump jr and we have uh
donald trump jr at donald trump jr his
book is liberal
privilege uh joe biden in the democrats
defense of the indefensible
wow uh some stellar timing how are you
mr don jr
i i'm doing well you know it was
interesting i i spent the
quarantine time starting in march
researching our opponent because i
couldn't go to work i you know i wasn't
going to loot and riot it's not really
my thing you got an exemption from
having to stay home if you were going to
loot and riot
uh and you know i started doing this
research and found a lot of this
corruption
it's hard to believe that even six
months later now the book i wrote is
actually
more true than it ever was that it was
always pretty damn accurate
but what's scarier right now we're
seeing
the potential president of the united
states prior to an election
literally being compromised by foreign
governments
his son dealing and peddling influence
all of the things stephen that they
hoped and prayed donald trump jr was
doing
right all of the things they ran with
for four years as that was the gospel
with exactly
zero evidence all of the things that
when they accused us we were totally
transparent put everything out they're
going here have at it
right hunter biden was actually doing
hunter biden's been doing for years
and now they're okay with it that's
right i mean when i look at what social
media has done trying to censor the new
york post you know it's the second
largest paper in new york
it's a 200 year old institution they did
this
and now the media that lost their
goddamn minds every time donald trump
called them fake news turns out he was
right about the russia hoax
now they're calling fake news on their
own journalists when the biden campaign
themselves won't even deny that these
things
are foreign that's a big difference
between
we showed this on on the program uh i
believe two days ago
when your dad was asked by the moderator
welker welker who will get into
about russia he said i never colluded or
worked with russia
it is a complete hoax and you should he
answered unequivocally denied it whereas
biden just goes yeah you would ask that
question uh
fat china yeah
now well and that's the thing and more
importantly then they put out this thing
well what joe biden didn't have that
meeting in his official calendar it's
like yeah no [ __ ]
he said no let me look at his google it
is i calendar ayatollah with iran and a
vpn okay
make some calls yeah you didn't put
corrupt meeting
with oligarch paying hunter billion
who's holding millions for
joe in the official white house calendar
not the question that was asked by the
way but they hear that and they say oh
this is freaking wonderful joe's clear
right it goes clear
and now you have the media literally
today and the democrats
and the never trumpers peddling like
iranian disinformation iranian
disinformation they're like
let's just send it out there because it
hurts donald trump can i clarify
something here because
right or hurt donald trump do you think
about how insane this is yeah and that's
something that's important because
it's been misrepresented they've tried
to say look the iranians actually were
sending
and russians are disseminating this
disinformation campaign
trying to intimidate voters and hold on
a second they sent false letters as the
proud boys to try and tip
do you really think that they're doing
that to try and help donald trump do you
really
like some of them say it's the proud
boys
donald trump that canceled the deal
where obama and biden gave them 150
billion
dollars donald trump canceled that
iranians really want donald trump to win
russia really wants donald trump to win
who put more sanctions on russia than
any administration including during the
cold war under reagan
no they want joe biden to win because
they know they've bought him off
imagine this stephen what they found
already on hunter
that's like one or two journalists
looking imagine they stick
you know 10 000 journalists on donald
trump jr like they did do it the hunter
imagine how much more they would find
yeah imagine how much more is there if
they were even willing to look but
they're not
and you know what if there's not if
there's not enough there just give him a
10 gram rock
and he'll give you everyone knows the
keys to the safe with hunter biden
let me let me ask you this is actually
giving me deja vu from when john kerry
officially endorsed osama bin laden i
remember it was so stupid that he
released it's like
if you want him to win osama don't say
no one's wanting your endorsement
um let me ask do you think well go ahead
but joe biden got the osama bin laden
endorsement too
in the raise they killed osama bin laden
they found the documents that were
classified at the end of last year there
are documents between osama bin laden
and his biggest henchmen saying they
wanted to kill obama this is back in
like
uh you know early obama admits they
wanted to kill obama because that would
put joe biden in charge
right
[Laughter]
and that by itself would lead to the
destruction of america because he's that
grossly unprepared
right even osama bin laden
right
by the way was the only other guy that
in america that didn't want to go in and
kill him i mean
this is the stupidity of joe biden and
that's well that's the thing they
thought if they got
they thought if they got rid of barack
obama would be easy to you know dangle
the carrot and kind of manipulate biden
and in biden's case it was an actual
dangling of the carrot they were going
to stand beside behind him with a
fishing pole
and a carrot and uh yeah that's that's
enough
maybe it may be a sick maybe a
six-year-old scalp you know just
go into it like yogi bear with a pie and
a windowsill just
um let me ask you this do you think any
of this will come up in tonight's debate
do you think there will be any questions
about this and if not
does does your dad have to bring it up
because there are mixed opinions on that
melissa i think he has to bring it up
you saw it was supposed to be the
foreign policy to debate
the second this stuff came out all of a
sudden they eliminated foreign policy
now they're gonna talk about climate
change i mean think about how stupid
this is
you know no one will talk about the
facts of climate change like according
to nasa
1.4 degrees since 1860
yeah 18 150 years 1.4 degrees like
yes that's why california is burning not
because of terrible forest management
not because of the environmentalists
refusing to let people in there to clean
up
some of the mess and standing dead
timber it's 1.4 degrees that made all
the difference in the world
it does it shouldn't surprise us though
anymore steven you saw the last debate
right
the last moderator was supposed to be
this great guy totally impartial turns
out he's a joe biden intern
he's sending never trumpers what he
thought was a dm
turns out it was just out on twitter
what should i hit trump with
and he lies about it and says that he
was passed
who are we talking about hey and
steve scully that was for the second
debate right okay yeah
right so he lies and says that he was
hacked that was for the was supposed to
be the second debate
so i said okay well if he was he's the
moderator of the second debate that
could be russian
interference in our lives you know well
that was a lie too
this one tonight is a is a former biden
administration person like
an obama administration person like so
i'm not expecting fairness
and when i see them trying to eliminate
the topics that would be dangerous to
joe biden like selling out
our country right uh it's me all i need
to know and i'm a little nervous because
uh steve was
uh steve who you're talking about but
standing with kristen welker i you know
the fact that she's been pinned with
biden's high school ring
a lot of people aren't talking about
that seems that should be uh more of a
story
but let me ask you this well foreign
policy listen the reason i don't want to
discuss that is because we have no new
major wars donald trump is the only
president modern american history to do
that and
hey some actual peace in the middle east
that got no coverage that's one of the
biggest peace treaties that is
it's the biggest one that's happened in
my lifetime between israel and the uae
and
this is obvious the economy foreign
policy
uh which they said would be donald
trump's weak suit remember when they
were asking about the arab spring and
these kind of trick questions
turns out you don't need to be a
political hobbyist to actually get
things done
and it would be irrefutable that donald
trump has done more for criminal justice
reform
and peace in the middle east than any
president in modern history it's just
not even up for debate i don't even
think van jones tries
no they they won't even you know the
problem is they won't even discuss those
sort of things if it's good for donald
trump they'll pretend it doesn't happen
i mean they
joe biden's gonna fix racial relations
in america
why do you wait no 47 years it's a long
time to build up right i mean
you know you you've seen that you have
guys in your show it takes a little
while to get them loosened up like a
minute
right 45 years is too long
if he really cared about these issues
you know you would think he would have
utilized i don't know 38 years in the
senate or maybe his eight years as the
first as the vice president of the first
african-american president but he
doesn't care
it's about pandering with these in the
middle east they spent more time
fact checking my sister's speech when
she gave at the rnc because it was that
time when she talked about her
three-year-old son building a little
lego white house
did he do it by himself
three he probably had a little bit of
help what's your point
but they would rather cancel a
three-year-old and talk about donald
trump's accomplishments
to be fair no you're true you're right
to be fair though
to be fair biden was very clear about
his racial relations plan it's the it's
the ring
rip van winkle approach so he's waiting
a long time i i think it's about 48
years
um let me ask his kids going to school
in a racial jungle
you know we talked about that ad nauseam
racial jungle it's like oh my god
i can't believe it if anyone in your
family said that this is the guy
this is a guy that was buddies with
every segregationist to ever walk the
halls of congress
and not just friendly like he eulogized
them at their funerals like
joe biden has no basis on this his crime
bill
everything donald trump reversed the
disaster that joe biden did
to those communities and yet you know
according to the media joe biden's going
to finally fix something after half the
century
right well it'll be good and then he
took a big steaming dump on on clarence
thomas
i'll never forget that a lot of people
don't realize you know what turned
andrew breitbart who was kind of my
mentor you know what turned him into a
conservative
was clarence thomas he said he tuned in
to watch them nail this guy and by the
end of it he said
oh my gosh they're going to crucify this
guy and he's innocent that's what turned
him into the andrew breitbart that we
knew
let me ask you this do you think that it
may actually be and i know listen i'll
talk with ted cruz about this too but
the debate commission we know is unfair
we know that it's biased but do you
think there may be a silver lining there
for joe biden to have two minutes all to
himself
by the way without question i think that
was probably what i would would have
wanted more out of the first debate
which is you know the problem is joe
biden got two minutes to lie so donald
trump then had to kind of correct the
record and they were both interrupting
and
interrupted first but the reality is
this yes there were times where i'm like
no just let them talk
just let them talk because this guy got
you know he can't remember what state
he's in 50 percent of time if you give
him unfettered talk we should just feed
all of our time and like it lasts
for two hours yeah because that won't
work out well for joe biden
um you know anyone who's watched him try
to give a speech
uh publicly has seen that i mean even
teleprompted it's disastrous
that's hard to believe because again
after half a century in the dc swap you
think you'd be able to read a
teleprompter but even that's the
challenge for joe biden well you know
he has myopia um let me ask uh well
first off again the book is uh liberal
privilege joe biden and the democrats
defense of the indefensible it's per
everyone i think everyone needs to read
this right now uh
two things i have a statement first the
one thing that i think would behoove uh
president donald trump is in the last
one rightfully so he was angry like you
said because of the moderator i think
when you look at the debates last time
particularly the second debate with
clinton you know what was really likable
about that is he seemed like he was
having fun
and so i think the more it seems like
donald trump is having fun and
even though he needs to be tough but is
there enjoying it i think that's when
he's at his best and then my last
question to you is because we do have to
go we have uh senator ted cruz waiting
on the line
um how do you expect tonight to play out
listen you know again i i do think it's
you know it's going to be a biased
playing field but you know listen my
dad's good at these sort of situations
he's a game time player he's willing to
tackle and challenge the norms that's
why we're getting results that's why
we're getting out of endless wars
that's why we're getting these deals
done in the middle east all of these
things that we've heard about for our
whole lives but no one's actually ever
evacuated
uh you know so you know i i think he'll
do well uh
despite sort of that bias i think you
know we do have to bring up some of the
things that the
moderators are going to do whatever they
can to avoid talking about the american
people deserve to know stephen
i mean again imagine it was donald trump
jr and not hunter biden
the republican party would step in and
say donald trump you must resign
you must step down right now remember
they were speculating that you had done
cocaine when at your speech remember at
the rnc you know they're like this
this guy is this guy makes charlie sheen
look like uh he
looks like a ron howard
yeah no it's uh it was crazy i mean and
that's exactly i think i think you have
me confused
with hunter biden but they won't talk
about that right again if i returned a
car with a crack pipe in it
or a rental car agency with my ip
i mean it would be a story i'm not
saying hey listen we all have our
our presentation problems get help i
don't drink for a reason it's not
because i was good at it you know what i
mean
right i get it oh it's true i'll call
this baby we all have our
but like i have a feeling that i
wouldn't get the sympathetic view
of those kind of problems especially not
if i was selling my country out for
millions of dollars especially if i was
making
millions with no ability to actually do
that you think the chinese gave
you know him 1.5 billion because he
wasn't a great investor or because he
was compromised
no i think that's where you can't look
at his record
if i was hiding for years from child
support payments
you think i'd get the benefit of the
doubt and say no i don't think you would
get the benefit
i wouldn't give you the benefit of the
doubt because i don't give anyone the
benefit of that but that just shows the
the arrogance right joe biden just
thinks he won't answer the questions he
doesn't deny the authenticity but if he
doesn't
answer the question the media will carry
his water same thing with the arrogance
of hunter biden leaving a crack pipe in
a rental car
if i smoke a cigar in a rental car with
a scenic view and the windows open
i put in some kitty litter and baking
soda and some febreze because
you know i don't want to get hit with a
250 bill but i do we do have to leave it
on that
i do appreciate you are one who calls
the spade a spade also
joe biden uh calls uh a spade a spade
so we will be back after this with
senator ted cruz the book is liberal
privilege thank you
so much don jr we must go
let us begin our quest now you donald
trump
need to bring what remains of joe biden
to
the embalming parlor my
undercrowder and i are making
preparations
i was about to break the mainly break
i'm not looking but i just feel like i
just saw
it the clock is ticking on the embalming
wall
joe biden will soon be mine
and be it that doesn't make any sense
soon creepy joe biden will be
yeah just do your thing your livers will
all
[Music]
rest
i live in a hole in the grove
[Music]
okay i'm excited because my next guest
has a podcast verdict that you can go
listen to
and he has a new book one vote away that
is about the importance of the supreme
court
and which cases have been determined by
only one vote and he's got the beard in
the mutton chops
and kisses all the girls in the
neighborhood and make him cry
senator uh ted cruz thank you for being
here sir
you know steven that there are
decaffeinated brands on the market that
are just as tasty
not for the nature boy a woo-woo
so um for people who can understand the
podcast is verdict
not the verdict which is one of my
favorite paul newman films with jack
warden
and uh the book is obviously one vote
away and i think
it's very important for people who don't
know it's not just about the supreme
court but about cases that were
determined by one vote
big one people not having the right to
own firearms at all a lot of folks don't
know about heller
but before we get to that let me ask you
what
do you predict for tonight we had you on
before the first
of what was supposed to be three debates
uh and we thought we'd have you back for
the last one we didn't think it would be
the second one
what do you think tonight will be like
and how do you think it may be
contrasted from the first debate
i hope tonight there's actually less
fireworks than the first one
uh i hope tonight the real division is
on substance
um the la the first one between trump
and biden was
was kind of a food fight i mean it was
there they were yelling and insulting
each other
right that's fine but but i actually
think that that
played to the democrats strength they
want it to be
all about personality they don't want it
to be about substance
what i hope the president does is draw a
clear distinction between free
enterprise and socialism i hope the
president draws
a clear distinction between rule of law
and the constitution versus anarchy and
riots in the streets and and i think
last time
the president was clearly ready for a
fight he was energized but i think a
couple of times he jumped in
and and and saved joe biden from himself
i think i think we would have been
better off if if he just let joe
talk a little bit because the positions
joe is embracing are really out there
and and uh the more we can do to
highlight it the better that is
we just talked about this yesterday
senator cruz nobody in this office
nobody in my research team nobody of the
15 people who work for louder with
crowder knew
that on joe biden's own website under
firearm safety is
he will ban all online sales of firearms
ammunition
kits parts that means if i want a grip
adapter
that's no one knows that and it's
surprising to me that
none of the there will be no question
seemingly in any of these debates
about guns and i think that that's
obviously trying to stack the deck
because
if people in michigan pennsylvania
wisconsin know how radical joe biden's
firearm policy is
he loses them on a landslide do you
think that's maybe the case here
i think that's right but i think it's
even more than that let me connect the
two topics we started with which which
is the debate
and and my book one vote away so each
chapter of the book is on a different
constitutional right
if you read the chapter on the second
amendment it talks about the case
heller versus district of columbia uh
that's the landmark second amendment
case it was decided 5-4 i helped
litigate that case
and in fact the book is all war stories
from helping litigate
many of the big landmark cases of the
court but on hillary the four dissenters
their position was not that some gun
control is sometimes okay uh reasonable
minds can differ on that we can have
actually a reasonable conversation and
debate on that topic right
the position of the dissenters was much
more radical it was that there is
no individual right to keep and bear
arms whatsoever
that it is merely a quote collective
right of the militia
which means the federal government the
state government the city can make it a
crime can make it a felony
for you or for me to own a gun
right and under the dissenter's view of
heller there'd be nothing we could do
about it we have no second amendment
right
joe biden has promised to nominate
supreme court justices
who would overturn heller so if joe
biden is elected
the supreme court will effectively erase
the second amendment from the bill of
rights that's the kind of substance
i hope we see in the debate tonight well
i don't know if we will
but i think it's important that uh to
note it's yeah it's not about heller
versus dc wasn't a pistol grip versus
tactical grip
it wasn't about some bump stock it was
about the right to own so when people
say i think i'm okay with revolvers
or pump shotguns no no that there you
would have no right to own it you'd have
to have some kind of
a sheriff or something someone like that
some legislator
or someone in local law enforcement
allow you the basic right to
self-preservation
going back to the debate and then i do
want to go ahead and specific facts on
it stephen so dick anthony heller who's
the plaintiff in heller
is a federal police officer lived in the
district of columbia
he carried a firearm at work um under
d.c
law all pistols were illegal so
revolvers any pistol was illegal no
matter what
and any long gun any shotgun or rifle
was required to be disassembled
and inoperative at all times with no
exception
so literally if someone is breaking into
your house if you're a single mom
and a crackhead is coming through the
window to hurt your kids
and you had a shotgun and you removed
the trigger lock
you were committing a crime let's not
bring hunter biden into this i don't
think he's breaking into anybody's house
anytime soon
hey lis hey come on come on that's not
that's not hearsay that's not gossip
he's on camera smoking a crack pipe
all right i have more credibility and
i'm in a feathered boa okay
uh let's go back to the debate here you
mentioned
uh you mentioned um yeah that that you
hope to see something more substantive
now i do want to talk about the
commission and how biased it is and what
we think we should do when elections
going forward however
could it be an advantage for joe biden
to be left alone with his thoughts for
two minutes straight
it may be a blessing in disguise
yes if there's the give and take of
of questioning and there has to be some
back and forth because look
joe biden can memorize a couple of
minutes and get it out i mean that's
what he's doing all week is memorizing
little set pieces where the debate is
important
and i'm all for trump counter-punching
and engaging
i i just hope he engages on substance
and
and sort of just turns the temperature
down a little bit and and and makes
clear
what what joe's radical policies are
right
and speaking of radical the uh the
moderator here i want to make sure
it's welker walker welker i always get
her name wrong uh we went through a
segment yesterday about her democratic
ties some of the practices that she's
uh undertaken as a journalist um she's
moderated debates before
should should american go americans go
in with eyes wide open
is she biased and then is the commission
bias the commission for debates who
changed the rules because i think a rule
change was fair
but this was pretty extreme look of
course she's biased of course the
commission is a train wreck
everyone on the commission is a never
trumper either the democrats or the
never trump republicans
they're all voting for joe biden and let
me say more broadly
republicans are idiots but
like if you look at debates every single
general election debate
is moderated by a democrat what the hell
is wrong with us like
100 everyone is moderated by a democrat
and it's even worse than that stephen
in the presidential race republican
primary debates
are almost all moderated by democrats
the people moderating
want everyone on the stage to lose and
every question is designed to make
everyone look like idiots
so i propose two very simple changes
okay number one for republican primary
presidential debates
the moderators should be people who
actually intend to vote in a republican
primary
that's right so if you're not a
republican don't moderate a republican
primary debate because we want
moderators who will actually ask
questions that republican primary voters
give a damn about
fair sec secondly for the general
elections stop
this ridiculous assumption that
journalists
are not partisans we've seen democrat
after democrat after democrat instead of
ignoring the bias own it and so have an
explicitly conservative
moderator and an explicitly liberal
moderator so imagine
for example a a debate moderated by
mark levin and rachel maddow
and everyone knows look levin's going to
ask tough questions and conservative
questions the democrats not going to
like
matto is going to ask liberal questions
the republicans not going to lie
and that actually would be an
interesting debate right
yeah at least the people on stage
wouldn't be the only ones trading barbs
it would be you know would you shut up
man hey screw
you ah screw you you dope no screw you
like which one's which i don't even know
anymore
but i'm enjoying it um let me ask you
i think it's a good idea because people
this idea that there is inherently
unbiased journalism that's a lot
it's never the case it would have to be
predicated on the idea that human beings
uh can have no values and if you have
someone with no values that mean
anything to them
well not only should they not be
moderating a debate but they should be
forced to walk the plank
uh you know i think drawing and
quartering is really under
undervalued in today's society
well yeah i mean uh so i see that you're
running for the green party with
republicans or idiots
let me ask you this too as well uh well
first final question on the debate and
we're going to get to that really quick
what's your prediction who comes out the
victor tonight and how do you think it
affects the election
i think trump's going to do well um i
think joe biden
i don't think biden is going to do well
i i i if
we can avoid the fireworks and focus on
substance i think trump wins tonight
yeah okay i think you're right and i
also hope that uh joe biden gets two
minutes to himself and
then just joe bidens himself you know in
two minutes that's that's the thing
sometimes you give him enough rope
we saw that with the last debate the one
time he was asked a direct question like
he said there has to be a give and take
that's fair
the one time he was asked a direct
question which ironically only came from
donald trump which law enforcement
agencies have endorsed you
um so my final question is obviously acb
is a conversation right now she's
probably going to be confirmed on monday
you introduced a constitutional
amendment to stop
or prevent any kind of court packing i
would say
as a block to a potential joe biden
presidency but
uh he doesn't know will he won't he vote
for him decide he hasn't given his
position
uh tell people what this is and why it's
important
so joe biden tonight is going to deny
again that he's going to pack the court
kamala harris has denied
that they're going to pack the court the
reason they won't answer that question
is because their answer is yes that
that senate democrats the radicals are
in charge
they're angry and if they win they will
pack the court what does it mean to pack
the court
it means to increase the number of
justices
to put your partisans on the court and
so we've seen
there have been nine justices in the
supreme court for 150 years we saw
another democratic president try to do
this fdr tried to do this at the
height of his popularity 1937 and his
own party the democratic party he had
huge majorities in both houses they said
no
they said it would politicize the
judiciary it would destroy the
independence of the court
we're not going to do it and
the reason that today's democrats that
biden doesn't want to answer the
question is because packing the court is
incredibly unpopular
and so here's what they're doing and you
can listen to it tonight
the last two weeks one of the ways we
know that that
they're going to pack the court a if the
answer was no they'd say no because it's
that's overwhelmingly the more popular
answer but
b democrats the talking points have gone
out
that they're trying to redefine what it
means to pack the court so joe biden
tonight here's a prediction he will say
donald trump has been packing the court
for four years
right by just actually having you know
uh conservative judges elected through
the process that exists
which is totally uh within precedent it
is
ludicrous spin to say that a president
nominating justices for vacancies
is packing the court that's not what
pacquiao requests ludicrous spin it's
spin plaid
but the re there's a reason it's also
spin that is revealing it's like a tell
in poker
the fact that they're trying to redefine
packing the court is because they intend
if they win to increase the court to 11
or to 13
and just jam a bunch of partisans there
who will do what
right who will take away the second
amendment who will take away our free
speech who will take away our religious
liberty
you know the book one vote away which by
the way stephen i
got to give you a shout out to you so
when i last went
went on on your show right before the
debate and we talked about the book one
vote away
it shot to the number one best seller in
the country on amazon
and and so you know that wouldn't mean a
whole lot to me if you weren't telling
it to all the hosts who had you on
but i do appreciate you making me look
guys
politics i know
no but i do no i appreciate it and i
think it's a very important book one
vote away because a lot of people
don't know the dissenting opinions
historically are
are really just as important as va votes
especially when you're looking at
actually packing the courts and to be
fair
joe biden may not have answered someone
could have turned on the microwave in
the green room and it made the plate go
a little bit haywire
uh the book is one vote away we do have
to get going
senator cruz we appreciate you being
here and uh i think we'll be seeing you
on uh on election night if i'm not
mistaken that's gonna be a marathon
stream of meat grinder senator cruz
thank you so much brother we appreciate
it excellent god bless we're going to be
right back
with more hopefully i'm going to pin
this so it's not so revealing
well it's the night we've all been
waiting for debate number two i'm
shaking in my boots with me as always as
gerald and audio wave
what kind of fireworks can we expect
tonight well steven the last debate was
a debacle but a lot has happened since
then and trump has really been itching
to have a second go
at rapey joe that's right first there
was covet and then the ill-fated zoom
debate which the president nix i think
we can really expect tonight
i'm getting word it looks like former
vice president joe biden is actually
arriving right now in his armored
vehicle
looking confident as he exits uh if
perhaps a little lost but he's got to be
feeling good about his prospect wait a
second i'm getting worried that the
commander-in-chief is already in the
building
talk about anticipation i'm gonna go
through down my leg just watching this
look at these two men these two dogs
have been staring each other through the
fence
and it is time to let the big dogs eat
mommy it's time to let the doggies out
oh my god mike
he just don't just hit the president oh
wait and then and my pet with a fooling
chair out of nowhere and it looks like
he's running i've seen kamala harris
i can't believe my eyes president trump
oh my word the game has changed
ladies and gentlemen you wanted a show
tonight well you certainly
are going to have yourselves a show
[Music]
[Music]
spirits
i hope you're all having a good night
today well we're looking for the new
president of the united states here in
chronometer we have the drinking game
rules we're going to have the promo code
crowder mania and you are home
to get thirty dollars off all your cheap
bastards who don't wanna sign up for my
club
to get thirty dollars off use the
hashtag of the promo code
crowder media cause i'm the boy who
kisses all the girls
in the neighborhood and um i think we
also
uh have uh hit the notification bell of
course uh because uh on youtube
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
we have a big show tonight yeah that's
going to be happening in studio with me
as always is quarter black
bear over here uh jake the snake audio
wave then we have to now and of course
on the uh
on the uh on the thing there he's over
there there he's over there
and uh i uh really quick we do have
drinking game rules tonight can somebody
bring up the drinking
game rules really quickly okay the drink
game rules read them for yeah
if trump gets a leading or unfair
question drops a thug life moment says
china fake news
if finish your drink if trump mentions
hunter biden let's see if that happens
biden
if he gets a softball question has a
dementia moment talks tough or says
come on man if he says come on and you
hear this sound
that means you drink but i just realized
it's actually um so all of you will be
drinking along with us we'll have
costume contest
uh rules really just wrestlemania themed
send them in you'll get a lock of gerald
morgan's hair who will be here soon
but i don't have a mug we don't have a
drink oh yes it's time for my undertaker
to come in
garrett would you drink
oh there he is he's here to bring the
nectar
[Music]
okay thank you very much thank you
undertaker oh i appreciate it everyone
else
oh yeah that's
all right we'll see you soon well that
was a lot of work
hey can you do me a favor audio actually
i do think i want program here oh yeah i
can't see anything
uh i wanted to read something for you
guys really quickly bobalinski just had
his press conference
yes he did who was a business partner he
claimed of joe biden right now it's just
blue and says field monitor
uh uh okay all right sorry sorry guys a
little bit of technical stuff it's hard
to make something bubbling this dynamic
bubbling
uh came out presented a press conference
where he said that he had proof he has
more cell phones that he's going to be
handing over the fbi
and he will be in the audience tonight
from what i understand he said that he'd
worked with hunter biden uh joe biden
it's not a hunter biden it's about the
leverage from joe biden
and the fact that he was involved in
this these business dealings that's what
he claimed there was a denial
that was issued so i'm going to read
this from you just issued online in case
you guys
have not read this yet against uh again
the promo code is crowder mania that's
the hashtag you get 30
off if you go to louder with crowder.com
slash mug club
um so this is the the the missile the
denial
right as chris wallace said on the air
about this very smear
vice president biden has actually
released his tax returns
unlike president trump erroneous that's
set up
and there is no indication he ever got
any money from anybody in these business
deals
do all of that rule remain to be seen
joe biden
never even considered being involved in
business with his family
nor in any overseas business whatsoever
here's the thing don't go so extreme
with
it yeah like it's a guy saying like i
have a girlfriend yeah really she
went she goes to another school okay all
right so we don't know and she lives in
canada what issues double d's what and
she was
in playboy really the cover
listen we can cross-reference that
pretty quickly how many canadians with
double d's
who are still currently in high school
we're on the cover of playboy
turns out none so give yourselves an
out by uh he has never held stock in any
such business arrangements nor has the
family member
what is true this is from the biden camp
is that tony bublinski admitted on the
record to breitbart that he is angry he
was not able to get in business with
hunter and james biden hold on a second
what business he said there was no
business
like i never even liked that chick
really what [ __ ]
she's an imaginary one this
is the denial um and they still have not
denied the authenticity of the emails
oh right about stock yeah which by the
way is something that everyone needs to
know out there
what happened to the bernie bros and
we're gonna i'm gonna get into what i
think should happen tonight or what will
happen tonight but the bernie bros big
money in politics biden is the candidate
of wall street of big banks big media
big tech hollywood
donald trump has the coalition of
working class
middle americans in law enforcement
military and ironically
union members not the union heads
because they have a contract with the
democrats effectively
and on a gentleman's contract a gentle
pricks contract
with the democrats but the people in the
unions don't feel represented so
who's who's who's the wall street guy
well
they're donating overwhelmingly to joe
biden what do i think will happen
tonight we have cnn right now with a
quadrant view um
look i talked with donald trump jr i
talked with ted cruz about this
i think there could be a real silver
lining for donald trump joe biden having
two minutes to himself
it's like you know joe rogan has those
sensory deprivation tanks yeah
and he always says you know when you go
in like all of your bad thoughts kind of
come back and you sort of have to work
through them
it's almost like joe biden being alone
with himself for two minutes without
someone helping him
might as well be an ayahuasca weekend
for him
like this guy's gonna get that for sure
it's his own
internal sweat lodge so i think that
could be a good thing
and i think like you you were saying uh
audio wade that donald trump can at
least use the theatrics if they mute his
mic to his advantage
oh absolutely yeah i think that all he
needs to do at a certain point is just
sort of point and be like all right well
yes this is what they're doing this is
their play this is how they're gonna try
to control it okay all right
and hands up don't mute
[Laughter]
and i think and i think donald trump
needs to come across as though he's
having more fun
the donald trump that people love is the
donald trump who laughed at hillary
clinton the donald trump who does the
white guy at white dad at a wedding
dance i like that
yeah that's fun with donald trump and so
last time he was angry rightfully so
i think it's a good thing if he doesn't
interrupt i think it's a good thing if
he looks like he's having fun
i don't think it's a good thing that
they removed foreign policy and national
security
we know why because joe biden is one of
the only people who didn't want to kill
bin laden and has
taken part in policy that's led to more
drone strikes than anyone and donald
trump has started us no new wars and the
biggest peace treaty
of our time with israel and uae you know
climate change is at the top of
everybody's mind
after 2020. that's what everybody's
thinking gets hot flashes i don't know
how he gets
hot flashes men aren't supposed to have
menopause well you know
[Laughter]
so i don't know what do you expect your
audience so i think that trump is
definitely at his best when he's dealing
with a hostile media
so he we saw that with the savannah got
three town hall he i thought he did a
good job i think everybody here
thought he did a better job than in the
past right uh i think because she was a
bully she was
so mean she was so witchy with a bee
that uh you know witchy [ __ ] woman
if i say it in a song it's okay exactly
donald trump seemed like
he was justified right absolutely yeah
and i think that if
he waits for that sort of thing to
happen here i think that yeah again
making the face or sort of pointing out
the selective muting
uh which i think is probably going to
happen yep uh really quickly we're going
to be talking about the supreme court
fighting covenant 19
american families racing america climate
change and they remove national security
i think they're about to take the stage
crowder mania is the hashtag
everybody watch along and uh send us
your chats we're going to be reading
them after uh
after the show once we go exclusively if
they stick to their plans
each one of them could could make
inroads i think but
um right now if they have a return fee
in the green room joe biden just said
hey [ __ ] i got to have a plan
oh didn't expect that one oh my word
yeah it would be so funny if he refuses
to come out because there's no
plexiglass
it's an unsafe environment trump had hit
pads because he was planning on checking
him into the boards
well he's immune yeah yeah i mean he has
a superpower donald trump
the fact that donald trump oh by the way
rem deserve desevere
approved by the fda as a therapeutic
think about this for a second
donald trump recovered in record time
people tried to say it was a hoax that
then
he didn't really have coronavirus
because he you know suffered the
symptoms that most people actually do
he used experimental treatment this man
actually at this point if you were to
believe the media these aren't approved
by the fda and he's doing operation warp
speed and he's going to grow a third
nipple and
kids with fish eyes and instead he
turned himself into a guinea pig for the
american people
and now this is an fda approved
treatment that could help
millions of people not only in the
united states but hey rest of the world
you're welcome
you're welcome that we're coming up with
these treatments and at least
applications of treatments as well if we
didn't actually create rem death severe
which i think we actually did
uh and then of course the people who
have a problem with it is the world
health organization yeah when we first
found out that trump had corona
everybody thought like oh this is really
bad for him because he played it down
for so long now he has it
and then immediately afterward they were
like oh he's just faking it to make
himself look better of course he's just
like you have and he touted unproven
treatments then the fda is like actually
we tested that [ __ ]
it's proven like no it's the why why do
you say no
because the organization that that works
with china and supports tedros and
denies the existence of taiwan
they said that it may cause a tummy ache
okay but it's proved by the fda i
thought you trusted science room
desevere is now approved by the fda to
help treat
kovid 19. okay is that not a good thing
in donald trump by the way remember they
said
only the kind of expensive treatment
that a wealthy person he wants to make
it available to all everybody
he wants to make it free for everybody
for crying out
loud i just don't know how they're going
to spin this outside of simply flat-out
denying it and saying that
vice president has actually released his
tax returns
who cares who cares if he's released his
tax returns
by the way those aren't the taxes we
want you don't get to purchase your
houses and your cars and
live the lifestyle that you do with the
taxes that you claim from years ago
we know that you your son hunter biden
it's not that hunter biden
it's not that they're there are these
these uh uh uh underhanded
seedy underground disgusting
uh business dealings it's that hunter
biden is effectively a shell
corporation for joseph right
it's not about hunter it's about joe
biden think of the leverage that they
and you know what you know that you
believe me because you also understand
that billionaires are tougher to buy and
sell if they have more money than you
do you really think you're going to
dangle a carrot with donald trump with
50 million bucks or or a retainer of 184
000
a month for crying out loud he gets that
he got he would get that when he was
making an appearance
with arsenio hall after celebrity
apprentice and that was with cutting
down the price because arsenio hall
was on the rider well yeah
shut up we get it we get it you're more
urban
well people have said that uh joe biden
surely there's some kind of secret bank
account or something something we'll
find with some
it it really is just hunter hunter is
the secret bank yeah
he just keeps all the money over there
yeah and i know but
also secret bank account and not just
that hunter himself acted as a secret
bank account for them but his his ass he
was a mule
here we go hey it's the lady who has
strong democratic ties and tipped off
hillary clinton with questions for the
campaign last time
kirsten welker kristen welker 20
president
this way between president donald j
trump don't you love how they tried to
make her look a little more ethnic
too tonight's debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
it is conducted under health and safety
protocols
designed by the commission's health
security advisor
the audience here in the hall has
promised to remain silent
no cheers foods or other interruptions
except
right now as we welcome to the stage
former vice president joe biden
and president donald j trump
oh god virtue let me take this mask off
here
[Music]
[Applause]
please donald trump just aerosol
particles like you're the joker in the
parade most of you this debate will
cover six
major topics at the beginning of each
section each candidate will have two
minutes uninterrupted
to answer my first question the debate
commission will then
turn on their microphone only when it is
their turn to answer
and the commission she doesn't have
power exactly when the two minutes have
expired
after that both microphones will remain
on but on behalf of the voters i'm going
to ask you to please speak one at a time
the goal is for which voters each other
which voters at savannah
every word of what you both have to say
and so with that if you're ready let's
start
and we will begin with the fight against
the coronavirus president trump the
first question is for you
the country is heading into a dangerous
new phase more than 40
000 americans are in the hospital
tonight with kovid including record
numbers here in tennessee
and since the two of you last shared a
stage 16 000 americans have died from
covid
so please be specific how would you lead
the country during this
next stage of the coronavirus crisis two
minutes uninterrupted
so as you know 2.2 million people
modeled out were expected to die we
closed up
the greatest economy in the world in
order to fight
this horrible disease they came from
china it's a worldwide
pandemic it's all over the world you see
the spikes in europe and
many other places right now if you
notice
the mortality rate is down 85 percent
uh the excess mortality rate is way down
and much lower than almost
any other country and we're fighting it
and we're fighting it hard there is a
spike there was a spike in florida and
it's now gone there was a very big spike
in texas it's now gone
there was a very big spike in zone it's
now gone
and there are some spikes and surges and
other places they will soon be gone
we have a vaccine that's coming it's
ready it's
going to be announced within weeks and
it's going to be delivered we have
operation warp speed which is the
military is going to distribute the
vaccine
i can tell you from personal experience
that
i was in the hospital i had it and i got
better and i will tell you that
i had something that they gave me a
therapeutic
i guess they would call what some people
could say was a cure but
uh i was in for a short period of time
and i got better very fast or i wouldn't
be here tonight
and now they say i'm immune whether it's
four months or a lifetime nobody's been
able to say that but
i'm immune more and more people are
getting better we have a problem that's
a worldwide problem this is a
worldwide problem but i've been
congratulated by the heads of many
countries
on what we've been able to do with the
if you if you take a look at what we've
done in terms of
goggles and masks and gowns and
everything else and in particular
ventilators we're now making ventilators
it will go away and as i say we're
rounding the turn we're rounding the
corner
it's going away okay former vice
president biden to you
how would you lead the country out of
this crisis you have two minutes
uninterrupted watch for the reactions
too 220 000 americans dead
you got nothing else i say tonight hear
this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
not anyone who's responsible for that
many deaths should not remain
as president of the united states of
america dementia moment we're in a
situation where there are a thousand
deaths a day now thousand deaths a day
and there are over 70 000 new
cases per day compared to
newpods what's going on in europe as the
new england medical journal said they're
starting from a very
low rate we're starting from very high
rate
the expectation is we'll have another
200
000 americans dead be timed between now
and the end of the year
if we just wore these masks president's
own advisors have told him
we could save a hundred thousand lives
and we're in a circumstance where the
president thus far and still has
no plan by the way no it's not a
scientific study
so i hope that gets fact checked by
facebook sure we have everyone
encouraged to wear
unless washed in a commercial washing
machine that gets hot enough does
nothing it makes it worse
fact check me youtube finally one study
that says his shitty little mask
his shitty little house on the prairie
head
dress
there's no science we're in a situation
now where
the new england medical journal one of
the serious most serious journals in the
in the whole world said for the first
time ever that this the way this
president has responded to this crisis
has been absolutely tragic and so folks
i will take care of this i will make
sure we have a plan
president trump i'd like to follow up
with you and your comments you talked
about taking a therapeutic i assume
you're referencing
regeneron you also said a vaccine will
be coming within weeks
yes is that a guarantee is no it's not a
guarantee but it will be by the way
within a matter of weeks and it will be
distributed very quickly can you tell us
which companies
johnson johnson is doing very well
moderner is doing very well
pfizer's doing very well and we have
numerous others
then we also have others that we're
working on very closely with other
countries in particular europe
let me follow up with you because this
is new information
now vaccine is coming soon within weeks
now your own officials say
it could take well into 2021 at the
earliest for enough americans to get
vaccinated
and even then they say the country will
be wearing masks and distancing
into 2022 is your timeline realistic no
i think my timeline is going to be more
accurate i don't know that they're
counting on the military the way i do
but we have our generals lined up one in
particular that's the
head of logistics and this is a very
easy distribution for him he's ready to
go as soon as we have the vaccine
and we expect to have a hundred million
vials as soon as we have the vaccine
he's ready to go vice president biden
your reaction
cornering follow-up questions to trump
let's see if she does that without i
would definitely agree to take a
coronavirus vaccine
if it was approved by the government
what steps would you take to give
americans the democratic party is
transparent have the scientists see it
know it look at it go through all the
processes and by the way
he's this is the same fellow told you
this is going to end by easter
last time it's the same fellow who told
you that don't worry we're going to end
this by
the summer we're about to go into it it
could go away like a miracle a dark
winter
and he has no clear plan and there's no
prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available hopefully unless you vote for
him for the america great great great
we're opening up our country we've
learned and studied and understand the
disease
which we didn't at the beginning when i
closed and banned
china from coming in heavily infected
and then ultimately europe
but china was in january what's that
little slippery i was saying i was in a
whiff of a six-year-old i should have uh
i should have you know moved quicker but
he didn't move quicker he was months
behind me
many months behind me and frankly he ran
the h1
n1 swine flu and it was a total disaster
far less
lethal but it was a total disaster
had that had this kind of numbers 700
000 people would be dead right now but
it was a far
less lethal disease uh look
his own person who ran that for him who
as you know was that chief of staff
said it was catastrophic it was horrible
we didn't know what we were doing now he
comes up and he tells us how to do this
also everything that he said about the
way every single move that he said we
should make
that's what we've done we've done all of
it but he was way behind us
vice president biden your response my
response is he is xenophobic but not
because he shut down
access from china and he did it late
after 40 countries had already done that
in addition to that what he did he made
sure that we had 44 people that were in
there
in china trying to get to wuhan to
determine what exactly the source was
what did the president say in january
he said no he said this is he's being
transparent
the president of china is being
transparent we owe more debt of
gratitude we ought to we have to thank
him
and and then what happened was we
started talking about using the defense
act
he told people to go to chinatown and
movie theaters in march
in march he had nothing he did and we
weren't anywhere
then he gets out of the hospital and he
talks about
where this is oh don't worry it's all
gonna be over soon
come on there's not another serious
scientist in the world who thinks it's
going to be over soon
president trump your reaction over soon
i say we're learning to live with it we
have no choice we can't lock ourselves
up in a basement like
joe does he has the he has
himself know he obviously made a lot of
money someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement or in a beautiful room in the
white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that
and kirsten every every meeting i had
every meeting i had and i'd meet a lot
of families including gold star families
and military families
every meeting i had and i had to meet
them i had to it would be horrible to
have canceled everything
i said you know this is dangerous and
you catch it and you know i caught it i
learned a lot
i learned a lot great doctors great
hospitals
and now i recovered 99.9
of young people recover 99
of people recover we have to recover we
can't close up our nation we have to
open ourselves
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have a nation
and of course the cdc has said young
people can get sick with covenants doing
well you can pass it yes
vice president biden i want to talk
broadly about strategy
though put your fake thumb down 30
seconds please and i have a question
no number one he says that we're uh you
know we're learning to live with your
pants
people are learning to die with it you
folks home will have an empty chair at
the kitchen table this morning
that man or wife going to bed tonight
and reaching over he sees an
empty crush is gone learning to live
with
come on we're dying with it because he's
never said
you said it's dangerous when's the last
time anyone heard the glimmer of hope
from biden
we do not want to tell them nothing
about fear dangerous america's crap
president's crap people are learning to
die you would think that this was uh
everyone was catching mass cancer
full responsibility it's not my fault
that he came here it's china's fault and
you know what it's not joe's fault that
it came here either
it's china's fault they kept it from
going into the rest of china for the
most part
but they didn't keep it from coming out
to the world including europe and
ourselves
vice president biden the fact is that
when we knew it was coming
when it hit what happened what did the
president say he said they're going to
overthink him
don't worry that's going to go away be
gone by easter don't worry the
warm weather don't worry march please
your party said go to movie theaters in
chinatown and fauci was talking about
cruises
things the president has said you can
bring that up with an overlay in case
you don't know we are
doubt your senses we're about to we're
going to take them 100 000 more people
president trump look perhaps just to
finish this
i was getting on that but just to finish
this when i closed
he said i shouldn't have closed and that
went on for months what nancy pelosi
said the same thing she was dancing
their streets in chinatown in san
francisco
he said this is a terrible thing you're
xenophobic i think he called me racist
even
and because i was closing it to china
now he says i should have closed it
earlier
it just joe it doesn't i didn't say
either of those things
you certainly didn't
in a different context it wasn't about
closing the border to chinese
coming to the united states all right i
want to talk about both of your
different strategies
in response to donald trump that's
obvious
is that do you want to respond to that
quickly vice president okay
let's talk about your different
strategies towards you no because
you suggested you would support new
shutdowns that's what they do they call
someone racist and xenophobic and they
know accountability
who are fearful that the cost of
shutdowns the impact on the economy
the higher rates of hunger depression
domestic and substance abuse outweighs
the risk of exposure to the virus
what i would say is i'm going to shut
down the virus not the country
it's his ineptitude that causes the
country
who's going to do it which companies
very specific
there have been no specific answers from
biden and no follow-ups from biden
i'm going to shut down the virus if that
were donald trump with vaccines
who's going to make it what's the
timeline can you guarantee it i'm not
shutting down tonight but there are
look they need standards the standard is
if you have a reproduction rate in a
community
that's above a certain level everybody
says slow
up more social distances
and do not open gymnasiums do not open
and get this under control hold up
slow down simmer up but when you do open
give the people the capacity to be able
to open and i want to build the economy
down do it safely
for example schools schools they need a
lot of money to program they need to
deal with ventilation systems they need
to deal with smaller classes
more teachers more pods and he's refused
to support that money or at least up to
now
let's talk about schools president trump
i think we have to respond to my mind
supporting school choices thank you i
just threw money at it
look all he does is talk about shut down
he's being very polite
his democrat government is cuomo in new
york you look at what's going on in
california you look at pennsylvania
north carolina
democrats democrats all they're shut
down so tight
and they're dying they're dying and he
supports all these people
all he talks about is shutdowns no we're
not going to shut down and we have to
open our schools
and it's like as an example i have a
young son he also
tested positive by the time i spoke to
the doctor the second time he was fine
it just went away
young people i guess it's their immune
system let me follow up with you
president trump you've demanded schools
open in person and insisted
to parents who worry that sending their
children to school will endanger not
only their kids but also their teachers
and family well the parents should
follow science
the transmittal rate to the teachers is
uh
very small but i want to open the
schools we have to open our country
we're not going to have a country
you can't do this we can't keep this
country close this is a massive
country with a massive economy people
are losing their jobs
they're committing suicide there's
depression alcohol
drugs at a level that nobody's ever seen
before
there's abuse tremendous abuse we have
to open our country
you know i've said it especially the
cure cannot be worse
than the problem itself because that's
what's happening
and he wants to close down he'll close
down the country by the way you know
who's against closed downs lockdown
the world health organization and now
even though he was for them now
i never said lockdown you're simply not
true
we ought to be able to walk and chew gum
at the same time we ought to be able to
safely open
but would they need resources here you
need to be able to manage your example
if you're going to open a business we
can't
have social distances within the
business you need to have if you have a
restaurant you need to have
plexiglas dividers so people cannot
infect one that's him bitching about
they're not being positioned
testing rapidly and know whether a
person is
in fact infected you need to be able to
trace you need to be able to provide
all the resources that are needed to do
this and that is not
inconsistent with saying that what
you've missed is three four four
and by the way all you teachers out
there not that many of you are going to
die so don't worry about it
so don't worry about it but if that's
true why shouldn't you say that follow
up with you quickly by the way i will
say this
if you go and look at what come on to
new york it's a ghost town
it's a ghost town and when you talk
about plexiglass these are restaurants
that are dying
these are businesses with no money
putting a plexiglass is unbelievably
expensive
and it's not interrupted i mean you're
going to sit there in a cubicle
wrapped around with plastic it's these
are businesses that are dying joe you
can't do that to people
you just can't take a look at new york
and what's happened to my
wonderful city for for so many years i
loved it it was vibrant it's
dying everyone's leaving new york take a
look at what new york has done in terms
of
turning the curve down in terms of the
number of people dying more deaths per
capita than anywhere
on earth blue state that'd be like
saying yeah look at what the leprosy
pit there's the states that are having
such a spike they killed all the lepers
the coronavirus
they're the red states they're the
states in the midwest they're the states
in the upper midwest that's where the
spike is occurring significantly
but they're all americans
and what we have to do is say michigan
pennsylvania 68
nursing homes why don't we talk about
that new york did well
pennsylvania did well already michigan
did well new jersey did well
let's compare it to say texas come on
now
the blue states have the worst economies
and they have the worst death rates it's
not even close you can bring it up
there's an overlapping
11 000 people in nursing homes president
trump whatever
spike take a look at what's happening
in pennsylvania where they've had it
closed take a look at what's happening
with your friend
where her husband's the only one allowed
to do anything it's been like a prison
now it was just ruled unconstitutional
north carolina and they've been closed
and they're getting killed financially
we can't let that happen joe
you can't let that happen we have to
open up and we understand the disease
we have to protect our seniors we have
to protect our elderly we have to
protect
especially our seniors with heart
problems and diabetes problems
and we will protect we have the best
testing in the world by far people like
joe
we have so many cases let me follow up
with you before we move on to our next
section president trump this week you
called dr anthony fauci the number one
best known infectious disease expert
a disaster you described him and other
medical experts as quote idiots
if you're not listening to them who are
you listening to i'm listening to all of
them including anthony i get along very
well with anthony but
he did see a question don't wear masks
hashtag
maniac has a promo code
i think he's a democrat but that's okay
he said this is not going to be a
problem
we are not going to have a problem at
all when joe says that
i said anthony fauci said and others and
many others and i'm not
knocking him a lot nobody knew look
nobody knew what this thing was nobody
knew where it was coming from what it
was
we've learned a lot but anthony said
don't wear masks now he wants to wear
masks
anthony also said if you look back exact
words here's his exact words
this is no problem this is going to go
away soon so he's allowed to make
mistakes
he happens to be a good person vice
president biden your response quickly
and then we're going to move on
very gracious because a piece of [ __ ]
president knew
in january didn't tell the american
people he was told this was a serious
virus that spread in the air
checked on anything sweetheart anything
at all look i've got the timeline can
you just say
donald trump knew in january and didn't
do anything where's the timeline here uh
gibby i thought you could put that
okay january 31st announced the chinese
travel restrictions and declared it a
public health emergency don't
panic your people said go to chinatown
as far as march
the new york times the other day that in
fact how about a follow-up
christian welcome it's a really
dangerous thing what happened
but from some of the brokers said sell
short because we've got to get moving
it's a dangerous problem well this is
i'm going to give you 30 seconds to
respond and then
the wall street i don't know somebody
went through you're the one that takes
all the money from wall street i don't
take it
you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals are
made you know i could raise so much more
money
as president and as somebody that knows
most of those people
i could call the heads of wall street
the hedge company
don't get more wall street
because you're the one that takes the
money from wall street not me
i could blow away your records but like
you wouldn't believe we don't need money
we have plenty of money in fact
we got plenty of money we beat hillary
clinton with a tiny fraction of the
money that she was in all right
gentlemen
don't tell me about the average
contribution 43 all right we're gonna
move on to our next section which is
national security
and i do want to start with the security
of our elections and some breaking news
from overnight just last night
top intelligence officials confirmed
again that donald trump
are working in a recorded call calling
an idiot
and we're not asking joe biden where his
money comes from
this is worse than chris wallace and i
hate that it won't get as much outrage
as chris wallace because the outrage
machine on the right what you do
this is far more subversive this is far
worse because people don't even know
what they're watching and i ask everyone
else to take the pledge
i made it clear that any country no
matter who it is that interferes in
american elections
will pay a price they will pay a price
what price it's been overwhelmingly
clear
this election this election
that russia has been involved china has
been involved to some degree and now we
learn
that that that uh iran because he wants
you
they will he wants you since they line
their you line their pockets with
billionaires
sovereignty
iranians my guess is he'd probably be
more outspoken with regard to the
iranians
but the point is this folks we are in a
situation where we have foreign
company countries trying to interfere in
the outcome of our election
his old own national security advisor
told him that
what is happening with his buddy well i
won't i shouldn't oh
i will his buddy giuliani he's being
used as a russian
pawn he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true and then you know why
he's not you know what he's tripping up
because he doesn't want to legally be on
the hook here he cannot write the emails
or not
sure the easiest thing would be right
now for joe biden and his beady little
doll shark soulless eyes to say those
emails are not real
he spoke broadly with russian
disinformation not being true kristen
welker if you do not ask him
about those emails point blank are they
authentic or not
you deserve to be fired he's engaged he
brought up committees that are
trying to destabilize all of nato i
don't know why he doesn't do it but
it's worth asking the question why isn't
that being done
any country interferes with us will in
fact pay a price because they're
affecting our sovereignty
president trump same question to you let
me let me ask the question you're gonna
have two minutes to respond for two
elections in a row now there has been
substantial interference from foreign
adversaries
what would you do in your next
let me respond to the first part as joe
answered
joe got three and a half million dollars
from russia and it came through putin
because he was very friendly with the
former mayor of moscow and it was the
mayor of moscow's wife and you've got
three and a half million
your family got three and a half million
dollars and you know someday you're
gonna have to explain why did you get
three to half i never got any money from
russia i don't get money from russia
now about your thing last night i knew
all about that and
through john who was john ratcliffe who
was fantastic dni
he said the one thing that's common to
both of them
they both want you to lose because there
has been nobody tougher to russia
with between the sanctions nobody
tougher than me on russia
absolutely between the sanctions between
all of
what i've done with nato you know i've
got the nato countries to put up
an extra 130 billion going to 420
billion dollars a year
that's to guard against russia i sold
while he was selling pillows and sheets
i sold tank busters to ukraine there has
been nobody
tougher mike lindell russia than donald
trump
i'll tell you they were so bad they took
over the the submarine port you remember
that very well
during he doesn't cry during you and
barack obama
they took over a big part of what should
have been ukraine you handed it to him
but you were getting a lot of money from
russia they were paying you a lot of
money
and they probably still are but now with
what came out today
it's even worse all of the emails the
emails the horrible emails of the kind
of money that you were
raking in you and your family and joe
you were asked president when some of
this was
those emails false and it should have
never happened and i could give him the
rope oh an explanation someone give him
the american people
why is it somebody just had a news
conference a little while
ago who was essentially supposed to work
with you and your family
but what he said was damning and
regardless of me i think you have to
clean it up and talk to the american
people maybe you can do it right now
vice president biden you may respond
with these strangers and then i do want
to follow up on the election security i
have not
taken a penny from any foreign source
ever
in my life we learned that this
president uh paid
50 times the tax china bank account
with china does business in china
and in fact is talking about me taking
money
i have not taken a single penny from any
country
whatsoever ever number one number two
this is the president i have released
all of my tax returns
twenty delegates that's the same talking
point twenty two years away tax returns
yeah but the email is real
really irrelevant if you're one of the
least successful businessman and
government which by the way
is why you support lockdowns you're
shutting down businesses to 25
do you think a restaurant can operate at
a 25 capacity with plexiglass
he has no idea
donald trump knows you can't operate at
25 capacity it's not the new normal
because it cannot be sustained
he's full of [ __ ] he's not answering if
kristen welker doesn't ask him
are the emails authentic this is like
all of my accountants she didn't answer
underwrote it didn't release them as
soon as we can i want to do it and it'll
show how
successful how great this company is but
much more importantly than that
people were saying 750 i asked them
a week ago i said what did i pay they
said sir you prepaid
tens of millions of dollars i prepaid my
tax tens over the last number of years
tens of millions of dollars i prepaid
because at some point they think what's
that michael i think
so i already prepaid it nobody told me
that
nobody told you that excuse me and it
wasn't written whenever they were
saying they keep talking about 750
dollars
but let me just tell you i prepaid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes
number one number two i don't make money
from china you do
i don't make money from ukraine you do i
don't make money from
russia you made three and a half million
dollars joe
and your son gave you they even have a
statement that
we have to give ten percent to the big
man you're the big man i think
i don't know maybe you're not but you're
the big man i think
you sense that we have to give ten
percent to the big man joe what's that
all about
it's terrible you have to ask the
question
[Music]
i'm going to let you respond very say
you're not the big man you're the little
man spoke to your
accountant about potentially releasing
your taxes did he tell you when you can
release them do you
think there's a deadline for when you're
going to
worse than the tea party got treated
because i have a lot of people in there
deep down in the irs they treat me
horribly we made a deal it was all
settled until i decided to run for
president
i get treated very badly by the irs very
unfairly but
we had a deal all done as soon as we're
completed with the deal i want to
release it
but i have paid millions and millions of
dollars
and i it's worse than paying i paid in
advance it's called pre-paying your
taxes i paid in it i want to ask you
both about the
pre-paid phone plan like potential
cricket entanglements and questions that
have been raised to give you both a
chance to produce
mobile broadly respond very quickly and
then i'll get to my question
why did he's been saying this for four
years
show us just show us stop playing around
dodging we're gonna hold this piece of
the fire
everybody knows what they do is you're
not
paying your taxes or you're paying taxes
that
are so low when last time he said what
he paid undertaking i'm gonna need a
refill make this one a little stronger
i know how to gain the system come on
come on folks
come on drink trump and then i want to
get it i was put through
a phony witch hunt for three years
it started before i even got elected
they spied on my campaign no president
should ever have to go through what i
went through let me just
say this mueller what is kristin welcome
to doing this
democrats what is she meant to be we
know that they spotted this campaign
they went through why does he have to
tell her to let him speak including my
tax returns
and they found absolutely no collusion
and nothing wrong
48 million i guarantee you if i spent 1
million on youtube i could find plenty
wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done and the kind of monies that your
family has taken i mean your brother
made money in iraq
millions of dollars your other brother
made a fortune
and it's all through you joe and they
say you get some of it
and you do very well you have houses all
over the place you live very well
all right gentlemen let me just ask some
questions about all of this broadly
oh man they're happy about the work
you're saying
when he's lying for a ukrainian energy
company when you were vice president
play poker with my troops oh man he's
bluffing anything about those
relationships inappropriate or unethical
nothing was unethical here's what the
deal what about inappropriate
with regard to ukraine we had this whole
question about whether or not because he
was on the board
thank you sir thank you let me give you
the uh a company
that somehow i had done something wrong
sorry i didn't quite get your intro
a single solitary person when he was
going through his impeachment
testifying for him said i did my
job impeccably i carried out u.s
policy not one single solitary thing was
out of line
not a single thing number one number two
the guy who got in trouble in ukraine
was this guy trying to bribe
the ukrainian government to say
something negative about me
which they would not do and did not do
because it
never talked about ever abandoned us on
here is there any reason this is not
totally fabricated and new in terms of
she should follow up on that
what are you talking about china i have
not had
the only guys to joe biden this guy he's
the only one huh
nobody else just made money from china
let me let me ask my question to you but
could i just one one thing very quickly
his son
didn't have a job for a long time was
sadly no longer is he considered
a military service i won't get into that
and he didn't have a job
as soon as he became vice president
barisma not the best look
not the best reputation in the world i
hear they paid him 1000
183 and they gave him a three million
dollar upfront payment all right
and he had no energy i'm going to let
the vice president go on to that quickly
and then i need to get to a question to
you very
no basis for that everybody investigated
that no one said anything he did was
wrong in ukraine
okay president trump this is for you
since you took office no you've never
divested from your business the guy who
works with you just before this who said
there was and just handed over laptops
and cell phones reference does
indicate that your company has a bank
account in china so how can voters know
that
you don't have any foreign conflicts of
interest it's just not going to happen
and they're all listed and they're all
over the place
man doing business the bank account
you're referring to
which is everybody knows about it it's
listed the bank account
was in 2013.
that's what it was it was opened into it
was closed in 2015 i believe
and then i decided because i was going
to do i was thinking about doing a deal
in china
like millions of other people i was
thinking about it
and i decided i'm not going to do it
didn't like it i decided not to do it
had an account open and i closed it okay
excuse me
and then unlike canada where he's vice
president and he does business
i then decided to run for president
after that that was before
so i closed it before i even ran for
president
let alone became president big
difference he is
the vice president of the united states
and his son his brother
and his other brother are getting rich
they're like a vacuum cleaner they're
such
okay we do need to move on i do want to
ask
my uh
makes charlie sheen look like droopy
eyed armless children but
he is not a kirby hey and please be
he has caused the deficit of china to go
up not down
with china up not down we are making
sure that
in order to do business in china you
have to give all your intellectual
property you have to get a have a
partner in china is 51
we would not do that at all number one
number two we're in a situation where
china would have never been more
property theft in the history of the
united states and under the obama
administration
here i was still vice president he said
we're setting up air identification
zones in the
south china sea you can't fly through
ask anyone or do you feel bad for him
because he already pooped his dependency
come on after that intellectual property
theft
ask about tpp ask about the uh about
nafta versus the united states mexico
uh agreement canada agreements like
north korea and
and the chinese president and putin and
others
and he pokes his finger in the eye of
all of our friends all of our allies
we make up only we mean like 25 percent
what'd you do for 95 percent you gave
iran money about the face
donald trump signed the greatest peace
and that's what we did enough holding
still tariffs and a range of other
things and we were president vice
president
all right let's talk you don't about
north respond to that
okay very nice
from chinatown after spending ten
minutes in office and being in
air force two number one number two
there's a very strong
email talking about your family wanting
to make
10 million dollars a year for
introductions president trump on china
policy though what nobody are you going
to do
that is exactly introductions to foreign
entities sweetheart
china is
i just gave 28 billion dollars to our
farmers taxpayers
taxes you're concerned with taxpayer
money i know the taxpayers it's called
china
china
they devalued their currency and they
also mike
you know who got the money our farmers
are great farmers because they would
target them
you never charged them anything also i
charged
25 on dumped steel because they were
killing our steel industries we were not
going to have a steel index okay
and now we have a stealing vice
president your response please
our response is look this isn't about
there's a reason why
look drink malarkey
the substantive issues it's not about
his family and my family talks it's
about you my man
looks and your family's hurting badly if
you're making less than
if you're a middle-class family they're
you're billing her middle-class families
okay
are making on average over four thousand
dollars more per year
in three and a half years of donald
trump compared to
a one thousand dollar game under eight
years of obama
will bring up the overlap middle class
families have never
seen fewer games fewer tangible
games quantifiable gains than under this
and keep in mind this not even under
this [ __ ] he was the lackey
he was obama's [ __ ] that's a technical
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything just a typical politician
when i see him let's talk about a
typical politician okay that's why i got
elected
let's get off the subject of china let's
talk around sitting around the table
come on joe you can do better we're
going to talk about oh yeah president
trump you've met with north korea i wish
you would have said the average
page increase but i've talked about your
beautiful letters with him you've touted
the fact that there hasn't been a war
or a long-range missile test and yet
north korea recently rolled out its
biggest ever intercontinental ballistic
missile
and continues to develop its nuclear
arsenal do you see that as a trail got a
lego
obama we sat in the white house right at
the beginning had a great conversation
was supposed to be 15 minutes and it was
well over an hour
he said the biggest problem we have with
north is north korea
he indicated we will be in a war with
north korea guess what
it would be a nuclear war and he does
have plenty of nuclear capability
in the meantime i have a very good
relationship with him different kind of
a guy but he probably thinks the same
thing
about me we have a different kind of a
relationship we have a very good
relationship
and there's no war and you know about
two months ago
he broke into a certain area they said
oh there's going to be trouble i said no
they're not
because he's not going to do that and i
was right look instead of being in a war
where millions of people sold you know
is 25 miles away
millions and millions of people
middle-class games
right now president trump vice president
biden to you north korea conducted four
nuclear tests under the obama
administration
why do you think you would be able to
reign in this persistent threat
because i did they just turned donald
trump's mic off they had to be part of
the deal because here's the right
they said why are you moving your
missile defense up so close why are you
moving more forces here why you continue
to do uh
um military maneuvers with south korea
i said because you guys don't have it
from north korea
and we're going to continue to do it
real median household income gained four
thousand one hundred forty four dollars
during trump's first three years over
five thousand
do something eight years of obama
he's talked about his good buddy who's a
thug a thug
and he talks about how we're better off
and they are have much more capable
missiles
able to reach u.s territory much more
easily than ever did before what are you
gonna do send over some drones president
biden you've said you wouldn't meet with
kim jong-un without preconditions are
there any conditions under which you
would meet with him
and i don't think about preconditions
i'm riddled with them down
nuclear capacity to get that the korean
peninsula should be nuclear free zone
all right let's move on to what's up
american family
who by the way look at the back of his
head it's like sonic he didn't like him
he was a point okay respond to that you
wouldn't
do it and that's okay you know what
north korea
we're not in a war we have a good
relationship you know people understand
having a good relationship with leaders
hitler before he in fact invaded you
what
the rest of europe come on it's the
reason you're not giving hand jobs
and they're far greater of a threat than
north korea
not only to us but to our allies
north korea was a mess and in fact if
you remember the first two or three
months questions tonight
it was a very dangerous period in my
first three months before we
sort of worked things out a little bit
okay there was a very they
left us a mess and obama would be i
think
the first to say it was the single
biggest problem he thought
that our country okay let's move on to
american families and the economy on
one of the issues about your family to
them is health care as you both know
today there was a key vote and a new
supreme court me and my family
next to the center of her thanksgiving
crack rock over 20 million americans get
their health insurance through the
affordable care
act and your administration
is advocating for the court to overturn
it if the supreme court does overturn
that law
those 20 million americans could lose
their health insurance almost overnight
so what would you do
if those people have their health
insurance taken away you have two
minutes uninterrupted
first of all i've already done something
that nobody thought was possible
through the legislature i terminated the
individual mandate
that is the worst part of obamacare as
we call it
the individual mandate where you have to
pay a fortune for the privilege of
not having to pay for bad health
insurance i terminate it it's gone
now it's in court because obamacare is
no good
but then i made a decision run it as
well as you can to my people great
people
run it as well as you can i could have
gone the other route and made everybody
very unhappy
they ran it premiums are down
everything's down here's the problem
no matter how well you run it it's no
good what we'd like to do
is terminate it we have the individual
mandate
done i don't know that it's going to
work if we don't win
we will have to run it and we'll have
obamacare but it'll be better run
but it no longer is obama it's not
because without the individual mandate
it's much different pre-existing
conditions will always stay
what i would like to do is a much better
health care much better
will always protect people with
pre-existing so i'd like to terminate
obamacare come up with a brand new
beautiful health care
the democrats will do it because
there'll be tremendous pressure on them
and we might even have the house by that
time
and i think we're going to win the house
okay you'll see but i think we're going
to win the house
but come up with a better health care
always protecting people
with pre-existing conditions very
important yeah we have 180 million
people out there
that have great private health care far
more than we're talking about with
obamacare
joe biden is going to terminate all of
those policies these are people that
love their health care people that have
been successful middle-income people
been successful they have 180 million
plants 180 million people families
under what he wants to do which will
basically be socialized medicine he
won't even have a choice
they want to terminate 180 million plans
we have done an incredible job on health
care
and we're going to do this who has an
advantage of never having actually held
an existing position where he'll say
he's not
your health care plan calls for building
on obamacare so my question is what is
your plan
if the law is ruled under the
constitution about those
people largely illegal immigrants people
chose not to purchase health care
without losing their plan
how about you asking about deductibles
going up an average of 200 something
percent
over two years how about premiums going
up 400 something percent
do not have the wherewithal to be if you
qualify for medicaid
and you do not have the wherewithal then
your state to get medicaid you
automatically are enrolled
providing competition for insurance
companies that's what's going to happen
secondly we're going to make sure we
reduce the treatment and reduce drug
prices
by making sure that there's competition
that doesn't exist now by allowing
the medicare to negotiate drug prices
with the insurance companies thirdly
the idea that i want to eliminate
private insurance the reason why i had
such a fight helping george by opening
up across 20 candidates for their
nomination was
across people to purchase plans based on
their health and [ __ ]
medical crazy old insurance
today under obamacare they did not lose
their insurance
unless they chose they wanted to go to
something else lastly
we're going to make sure we're in a
situation if they like their doctor they
should keep their doctors that turns out
that they couldn't know
or one in three doctors will not take
medicare or medicaid anymore
it's a huge number for a long time there
is no he's never committed
i guess we're going to get the brexit to
bring that overlapping at the same time
we get the infrastructure plan
that we've waited since 17 18 19 and 20.
the fact i still have a little a few
more minutes i know you're getting that
she's 20
years old the fact is that he's already
cost the american people because of this
terrible handling of the cova virus and
the
economic
spillover 10 million people have lost
their
private insurance away 22 million more
people who haven't understood
over 110 million people with
pre-existing conditions
and all the people from covert are going
to have pre-existing conditions
what are they going to do i have a
follow-up for you vice president biden
it relates to something
a follow-up accusing you of wanting
socialized medicine what do you say to
people
who have concerns that your health care
plan which includes a government
insurance option takes the country
one option to a health care eliminating
the free market
that's how it's always ridiculous it's
like saying that you know
we're uh the idea that the fact that
there's a public option that people can
choose that makes it a socialist plan
here's what happens the difference
between private insurance can kill it's
just like those laws
anti-trust laws anti-monopoly laws let's
say there are four gas stations on the
corner you don't even hear joe biden
right now it's really quick let's say
there are four gas stations
one company owns three right owns three
gas stations
drives the price down even though
they're losing money
so that that fourth gas station goes out
of business and they drive the prices
back up
that's what the public option is the
public option doesn't have to be
efficient doesn't matter if there's red
tape
insurance companies try to compete and
then someone like joe biden says throw a
couple more trillion dollars at it
all of a sudden private insurance goes
out of business there's no competition
there's no accountability
and then you end up with a 52 income tax
rate like you have in my home province
of quebec
or the income tax rate in a state like
california or new york of i think 62
percent which is why 50 cent endorsed
donald trump public option is socialized
health care don't buy the [ __ ]
for eight years and it's not like it was
25 years ago it was
three and three quarters it was just a
little while ago right
less than four years ago he didn't do
anything he didn't do it
he wants socialized medicine and it's
not that he wants it his vice president
i mean she is is more liberal
than bernie sanders and wants it even
more bernie sanders wants it
the democrats want it if you're going to
have socialized medicine just like you
want to with fracking
we're not going to have fracking we're
going to stop cracking we're going to
stop fracking then he goes to
pennsylvania after he gets it
and you never ask that question and by
the way so far i respect very much the
way you're handling this i have to say
by the way but somebody should ask the
question michael you can ask he goes
my response is people deserve to have
affordable health care period
period period period and the buy care
proposal will in fact
provide for that affordable health care
lower premiums what we're going to do is
going to cost some money why did you not
crosstalk
premiums went up deductibles went up
record numbers pharmaceuticals went up
there's one guy on this stage right now
one guy who's the first president
in the history of modern america to
bring down the average cost of drug
prices
it's the guy with
he's talking about socialized medicine
yeah he and yes and healthcare
when he talks about a public option he's
talking about destroying your medicare
totally district and destroying your
social security and this whole country
will come down
you know bernie sanders tried it for his
state he tried it at a state and he
remembered his governor
was a very liberal governor they want to
make it work okay let's hear vice
president
very confused guy he thinks he's running
against somebody else he's running
against
joe biden i beat all those other people
because i disagreed with them
joe biden he's running against and the
idea that we're in a situation that
they're going to destroy medicare
this is the guy that the actuary
medicare said
if in fact at social security if in fact
he continues to
withhold his plan to withhold the tax on
social security
social security will be bankrupt in by
2023
with no way to make up for it this is
the guy who's tried to get eight years
to fix medicare
you raided the social security fund
[ __ ] to fund companies like the
lingerie social
if i'm elected if he's elected the stock
market will crash
okay let's get his financial next
question very quickly
look the idea that the stock market is
booming is his only measure of what's
happening
where i come from in scranton and
claymont that people don't live off of
the stock market
just in the last people when everyone in
wall street gives you money
the billionaires in this country made
according to the wall street
700 billion more dollars 700 billion
more dollars
because it's better than makes 5 000
more per year the average american
family let's talk
under you the average american family
joe didn't even outpace inflation
all right he didn't make an old circus
monkey that's like one of
he lived there for a short period of
time before he even knew
as of tonight more than 12 million
people are out of work
and as of tonight eight million more
americans have fallen into poverty
and more families are going hungry every
day those hit hardest are women
and people of color they see washington
fighting over a relief bill
mr president why haven't you been able
to get them the help they need
30 seconds here because nancy pelosi
doesn't want to approve it i do
but you're the president i do but i
still have to get unfortunately that's
one of the reasons
it doesn't do it all by mandating they
understand parameters
because she'd love okay 1.8 trillion
he's trying to do the proper systems
the other guy says he'll just force
everyone to wear masks
don't forget we've already approved
three plans and it's gone through
including the democrats in all fairness
this one she doesn't want it's near the
election because she thinks it helps her
politically
i think it hurts her politically all
right mr vice president no the
republican leader in
in the united states senate said he
can't pass it he will not be able to
pass it
he does not have republican votes why
isn't he talking to his republican
friends
let me follow up with you vice president
why have you not pushed the democrats to
get a deal for the american people well
i have and they have pushed it look they
passed this act
all the way back in the beginning of the
summer this is like it's not never
it's been out there this heroes act has
been sitting there
and look at what's happening when i was
in charge of the recovery act with 800
billion dollars
i was able to get 145 billion dollars to
local communities
that have to balance their what about
the state's fair dollars what happened
to that when he was talking about
earlier whereas donald trump was
discussing something that was directly
funded by
taxes on china i got 100
billion dollars he's running he will not
support that
they have not done a thing for them 1.8
trillion your party said no
1.8 trillion your party said no 1.8
trillion democrats said no
1.8 trillion democrats have said no was
a bailout
of badly run high crime democrat
all run by democrats cities and states
it was a way of getting a lot of money
billions and billions of dollars to
these kids it was also a way of getting
a lot of money
from our people's pockets to people that
come into our country illegally
we were going to take care of everything
for them and what that does and i'd love
to do that i'd love to help them but
what that does
everybody all over the world will start
pouring into our country we can't do it
this was a way of taking care of them
this was a way of spending on things
that had nothing to do with covert as
for your question
but it was really a big bailout for
badly run
democrat cities and states all right if
i get elected i'm not gonna
i'm running as a proud democrat but i'm
going to be an american president oh
that's something
like vin diesel in the late night i
don't want to go to the united states
and folks every single state out there
finds themselves
in trouble they're going to start laying
off whether they're red or blue red
firefighters first responders because
teachers
because they have to balance their
budget and the founders were smart
sorry police officers military
firefighters
and teachers shut the hell up i'm so
sorry
teachers are going into a burning
building right
like teachers have a villain that you
would see in backdraft for crying out
loud
you might have a kid who eats paste i'm
sorry teachers
thank you for what you do but you are
not first responders
you are not the firefighters at in 911
the important people were nypd
fdny and the military
it's not you teachers i'm sorry i'm
tired of i'm tired of deifying teachers
it allows us
to be able to call people work nine
months a year supposed to go to help
them do everything from
organize how they can deal with their
businesses being open safely
schools how they can make classrooms
smaller how they can hire more teachers
how they can put ventilation systems in
they need the help the businesses as
well as the schools need the help
open up but this because these guys will
not help them
is not giving them any of the money we
are going to there's nothing
this guy won't help with the money and
the help the minimum wage that's not
helping
i i think it should be a state option
alabama
is different than new york new york is
different from vermont
every state is different it should be a
state option you said very well you have
to help it's very important
we have to help our small businesses how
are you helping your small
use christian welfare wages what's going
to happen and what's been proven to
happen
is when you do that these small
businesses fire many
of their employees not true raising the
federal minimum wage to fifteen dollars
an hour
you said recently you would consider
raising the federal minimum wage
that's still the case and i would
consider it in it to an extent but it
was
really illegal in a second
administration but
not to a level that's going to put all
these businesses out of business
it should be a state option look
everything different places i know
different places they're all different
here's something you can choose fifteen
dollars is the average american family
has increased their wages by over five
thousand dollars
in four years of donald trump you can
pick that or 15 an hour and put the
average american family
out of business or into a single income
household that's your choice
of fish 17 an hour
because they've allowed us to make it
what's happening they deserve
a minimum wage of fifteen dollars
anything below that's
below the poverty more than fifteen
there is no evidence that when you're
talking businesses go out of business
that is
just first responders don't make 15
hours
an hour they make us survive and they
make this first responder they deserve
more
in this context mr president your
administration separated children from
their parents at the border
but the united states can't locate the
parents of more than 500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited children
are brought here by coyotes and lots of
bad people
cartels and they're brought here and
they used to use them to get into it
we now have as stronger borders
400 miles a brand new wall you see the
numbers and we let people in but they
have to come in legally and they come in
through but how will you reunite let me
just tell you guys with their family
they built cages you know they used to
say i built the cages
and then they had a picture in a certain
newspaper
and it was a picture of these horrible
cages and they said look at these cages
president trump built them and then it
was determined they were built
in 2014. that was him yeah they built
this
reunite the kids yes we're working on it
very we're trying
very hard but a lot of these kids come
out without the parents they come over
through cartels and through coyotes
know your [ __ ] kristen wilker these 500
plus kids
came with parents they separated them at
the border
to make it a disincentive to come to
begin with no
because the flora's consent policy
deemed it cruel and unusual treatment of
children to imprison them the way they
would with parents
that is why people need to understand
this kristin welker either knows this
and is lying
or she is an idiot unfit to moderate
this debate
you need someone who's sharp enough to
call someone on their [ __ ]
and that's all biden is he's a walking
pile of corn infested [ __ ]
with googly eyes let's talk about what
we're talking about what happened
parents were ripped their kids were
ripped from their arms
and separated no and now they cannot
find over 500 we have a loaded wall
nowhere to go nowhere to go it's
criminal
it's criminal let me ask you i will say
this they went
one question who built the cages i'd
love you to ask him that
who built the cages let me ask about
your immigration policy mr vice
president
of the question christian immigration
leading false question who built the
cages
who built the cages who built the cages
as well as family detentions at the
border before changing
so why should voters trust you with an
immigration overhaul now
because we made a mistake it made two it
took too long to get it right
immigration right i'll be president
united states not vice president united
states
and the fact is i've made it very clear
really all over within 100 days i'm
going to send to the united states
congress
a pathway to citizenship for over 11
million undocumented people
and holy [ __ ] so-called everyone should
repeat that on a loop like a morphine
drip immediately
he's going to give a pass to citizenship
right away to 11 million
undocumented immigrants meaning illegal
aliens
someone should put that on a on a loop
like a morphine drip
and just put that on the michigan
wisconsin and pennsylvania airwaves
send it to the steel workers union send
it to the uaw
he just said that 11 million people who
will take
four five six seven dollars an hour
people who have no interest in the
american economy and the average
american worker that he will give him a
pathway to citizenship
and to vote if that makes it on the
airwaves
in the midwest in that rust belt
key demographic right now he loses the
election
i bet you they won't talk about it he is
immediately going to give a pathway to
11 million
if that happens there goes the united
states of america yeah because we
already calculated over 2 million
compromised potentially compromised
votes in this election
now let's add 11 million people who are
indebted to biden because he used
taxpayer dollars to give them free
citizenship to the most valuable country
that has ever granted citizenship in the
history of the united states
came across and they were arrested they
in fact were given a date to show
up for their hearing they were released
and guess what they showed up
for a hearing this is the first
president in history what about the ones
who are released and raped
people seeking a piece of [ __ ] has to do
or murder the country
that's never happened before in america
that's never happened before in america
you come to the united states and you
make your case that i
seek asylum based on the following on
the following premise why i deserve it
what promises squalor on the other side
we have to be fleeing
a persecute a persecuting government not
just
my country sucks we get it all of south
america sucks
that's not enough of a reason the reason
that ronald reagan the reason that
americans
have a heart for cuban america who by
the way overwhelmingly republican when
they come here
and they kiss the soil they vote
overwhelmingly republicans because they
are fleeing a government
who will kill them if they speak out
against the government
or they play the saxophone they are
fleeing a government that is persecuting
them
while by the way your administration
took a picture in front of the
persecutor
che guevara the only warlord by the way
to be found i think in bolivia with a
rifle that had never been fired
cuban americans want to be american and
they're fleeing a persecuting government
that's not the same with people fleeing
a shitty country
with the lowest iq they might come back
okay president trump let's give vice
president
a chance to respond and then we're going
to move on to that
vice president biden your response know
the law what he's telling you is simply
not true
check it out they don't come back check
it out all right let's move but we don't
have to worry about it because they
terminated it so we'd have to worry
about it
that's right to the next 525 kids not
knowing where in god's name they're
going to be and lost their parents go
ahead
all right let's talk about our next
section which is
race in america and i want to talk about
the way black and brown americans
experience race in this country part of
that experience
is something called the talk it happens
regardless of class
and income parents should feel they have
no choice
but to prepare their children for the
chance that they could be targeted
including by the police for no reason
other than the color of their skin
[ __ ] in the next two minutes i want
you to speak directly to these families
do you understand why this is going to
be the most pandering answer we've heard
of the night
i do you know my daughter is a social
worker
and uh she's all she's written a lot
about this she's a has a graduate degree
from the university of pennsylvania and
social work
and you know uh one of the reasons why i
ended up working on the east side of
wilmington delaware which is
90 african-american was to learn
more about what was going on what i
didn't i never had to tell my daughter
if she's pulled over make sure she puts
for a
traffic stop put both hands on top of
the wheel and don't reach for the glove
box because someone may shoot you
but a black parent no matter how wealthy
or how poor they are
has to teach their child when you're
walking down the street
don't have a hoodie on when you go
across the street making sure that you
in fact
if you get pulled over yes yes sir no
sir
hands on top of the wheel because you
are
just describing your white daughter a
person making 300 everybody's child
300 000 every year person or someone
who's on
on on food stamps the fact of the matter
is
there is can you say all blacks are on
food stamps
did i just hear that i think that's true
did i just hear that
yeah that is what he said what a
this is the first president to come
along and says that's the end of that
we're not going to do that anymore we
have to provide for economic energy end
of keeping blacks on food stamps
yeah you know what i'd be better off
schooling better actually you want to
liberate
your marriage that's why we have a
number of businesses all the things we
can do and i've laid out a clear plan
as to how to do those steps just to give
people a shot
it's about accumulating the ability to
have wealth as well as it is
to be free from violence what president
trump requests
you remind you of this oh
yes i do and again he's been in
government 47 years he never did a thing
except in 1994
when he did such harm to the black
community
and they were called and he called them
super predators
and he said that he said it's super
predators
and they kept never in racial jungle in
1994
the crime bill the super predators
nobody has done more for the black
community than donald trump and if you
look
with the exception of abraham lincoln
possible exception but the exception
nobody has done what i've done criminal
justice reform
obama and joe didn't do it
i don't even think they tried because
they had no chance at doing it
they might have wanted to do it but if
you had to see the arms i had a twist to
get that
done it was not a pretty picture and
everybody knows it including some very
liberal people that
cried in my office they cried in the
oval office two weeks later they're out
saying gee we have to defeat him
criminal justice reform prison reform
opportunity zones with tim scott a great
senator
from south carolina he came in with this
incredible idea for opportunity zones
it's one of the most successful programs
people don't talk about it tremendous
investment is being made biggest
beneficiary
the black and hispanic communities and
then historically black
colleges and universities after three
years of coming to the office i love
some of those guys they were great
they came into the office and they said
i said what are you doing after three
years i said why do you keep coming back
because we have no funding i said you
don't have to come back every year we
have to come back
because president obama would never give
them long-term funding
and i did 10-year long-term funding
and i gave them more money than they
asked for because they said i think you
need more
and i said the only bad part about this
is i may never see you again
because i got very friendly with them
and they like me and i like them
but i saved colleges and universities
okay and we're going to talk about the
very inspiration
based on falsehoods you get shot and
listen uh blacks need to be on welfare
and uh violence and donald trump says
here's what i've done and this is my
vision for black americans
and by the way his vision for black
americans is exactly the same
as how he described the vision for all
working middle class americans
enough people joe biden just said you're
gonna get shot no one cares about you
and you need to vote for me in food
stamps he talked about there's no
positivity there's no vision
he this is very clear tonight donald
trump loves america
and believes in america joe biden
america is a useful tool for his
election campaign he doesn't get what
it's about
he certainly doesn't get what black
americans are about of what the crime of
the crimes they were
suggested look and talk about he
granted he did in fact let 20 people he
committed 20 people sentences
we committed over a thousand people's
sentences over a thousand
the very law he's talking about is the
law that in fact
initiated by barack obama and secondly
we're in a situation here where what
about your law the foreign
in modern american history what about
those laws no minimum
mandatories in the law that's why i'm
offering 20 billion dollars of states to
change their state laws
to eliminate minimum mandatories and set
up drug courts no one should be going to
jail
because they have a drug problem they
should be going to rehabilitation
not to jail we should fundamentally
change the system and that's what i'm
going to do
but why didn't he do it four years ago
why didn't you do that four years ago
even less than that why didn't i when
you were vice president you keep talking
about all these things you're gonna do
and you're gonna do this but you were
there just a short time ago
and you guys did nothing we did you know
joe i i ran because of you
i ran because of the barack obama you
did a poor job
if i thought you did a good job i would
have never run i would have never run
i ran because of you i'm looking at you
now you're a politician i ran because of
you
all right vice president biden your
response to that and then i do have some
questions for both of you well i'll tell
you what
i uh i hope he does look at me because
what's happening here is
you know who i am you know who he is
you know his character you know my
character you know our reputations for
honor and telling the truth
i am anxious i am anxious to see this
take place i am the character of the
country is on the ballot
our character is on the ballot look at
us closely let me ask some folks
oh my gosh i'm a character
china other countries iraq people say
this is true
he's a character for the characters so
don't give me the stuff about how you're
this innocent baby
joe they're calling you a corrupt
politician nobody president trump i want
to say nobody nobody's lovely
some people are calling you no you are
but what am i
only those who served 48 years and have
never held private gainful employment
corrupt politicians
go screw yourself joe former heads of
the c.i.a both parties
say what he's saying is a bunch of
garbage nobody believes it except
his and his good friend rudy gianni you
mean the laptop
here we go again with russia we're going
to continue on the issue of race mr
president you've described
the black lives matter she came in in
record time to rescue joe biden because
she realized he might talk himself into
a legal corner
i have never seen that before she
realized he was about to talk himself
into a legal corner because he's
[ __ ]
and so she decided she was going to step
in and save him
she shot the noose like the good the bad
and the ugly she shot it off for him
the first time i ever heard of black
lives matter they were chanting
pigs in a blanket talking about police
pigs pigs talking about our police
pigs in a blanket fry them like bacon
i said that's a horrible thing and they
were marching down the street
and that was my first uh glimpse of
black lives matter i thought it was a
terrible thing
as far as my relationships with
all people i think i have great
relationships with all people
i am the least racist person in this
room
what do you say to america
they can say anything i mean they can
say anything
it's a very it makes me sad because i am
i
i am the least racist person i can't
even see the audience because it's so
dark
but i don't care who's in the audience
i'm the least racist person
in this room okay vice president biden
let me ask you
very quickly and then i have a follow-up
question for you abraham lincoln here is
one of the most racist presidents we've
had in modern history
he pours fuel on every single
racist
you're the one who said racial jungle
you're the one who had a crime bill oh
you're the one who supported
segregationists
you're the one who was only one
hopscotch seat away from robert byrd who
was recruiting for the clan
you're the one i don't even think you're
racist joe but if i had to
if i had to have a scale you would you
would weigh more than the duck
you said you were abraham i know where
did that no no
you said i said not since abraham
lincoln has
anybody done what i've done for the
black people
not since abraham lincoln has anybody
done what i see when joe gets caught he
laughs
now you have done nothing other than the
crime bill
which put oh god that tens of thousands
of black men mostly in jail all right
you know what let me remember you look
at what's happening with the voting
rights there you go
very very badly just take a look at
what's happening out there vice
president
let me give you a chance to respond
within this context crime bills that you
supported in the 80s and 90s
contributed to the incarceration of tens
of thousands of young black men
who had small amounts of drugs in their
possession they are sons they are
brothers their fathers their uncles
whose families are still to this day
some of them suffering the consequences
so speak to those families why should
they vote for you one of the things
is that in the 80s we passed 100
all 100 senators voted for it a bill on
drugs and how to deal with drugs it was
a mistake
i've been trying to change the since
then particularly the portion of course
that's why i've been arguing right in
yes please not
send anyone to order for a
pure drug offense they should be going
into treatment
across the board that's what we should
be spending money that's why i set up
drug courts which were never funded
by republican friends they should not be
going to jail
for a drug or an alcohol problem they
should be going
into treatment treatment that's what
we've been trying to do that's what i'm
going to get done
because i think the american people have
now seen that in fact it was a mistake
to pass those laws related to the drug
but they were not in the crime bill
but why didn't he get it done see it's
all talk no action with his politicians
why didn't he get it done that's what
i'm gonna do when
why didn't you get it done you had eight
years to get it done now you're saying
you're going to get it done
because you're all talk and no action we
got a lot of it done
we released 38 they got 38 000 prisoners
left
you got nothing done 38 000 prisoners
were released from federal prison
we have there were over a thousand
people who were given clemency
we make fact we're the ones that put in
the legislation saying
we could look at pattern and practice
the police department so what they were
doing
how they were conducting themselves i
could go on but we began the process
we began the process we lost an election
that's why i'm running
to win back that election and change his
terrible policies
why didn't you do it in the eight years
a short time ago why didn't you do it
you just said i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna do this
you put tens of thousands of mostly
black young men in prison now you're
saying you're going to get
you're going to undo that why didn't you
get it done you had eight years with
obama
yeah you know why joe because you're all
talk no let him answer
all right vice president biden and then
we're going to move on to the next
section oh joe biden didn't have
anything
in congress
that hurt me we're going to move on to
our next section like i did with
criminal justice reform i had to talk
democrats into this gentleman
you're dead we're running out of time so
we gotta get on to
that change please you both have very
different visions on clients oh god is
it almost over
the ideas or bills had been proposed or
pushed forward by joe biden
and you could say that the congress said
no
that didn't happen
but what i want is the cleanest crystal
clear water
the cleanest air we have the best lowest
number in
carbon emissions which is a big standard
that i notice
obama goes with all the time not joe i
haven't heard joe use the term because
i'm not sure he knows what it represents
or means
and we have the best carbon emission
numbers that we've had in 35 years
under this administration we are working
so well
i need to wish you bill it can be vino
or whatever look at china
about how filthy it is look at russia
look at india it's filthy the
the air is filthy the paris accord i
took us out because we were going to
have to spend
trillions of dollars and we were treated
very unfairly
when they said they did us a great deal
they were going to take away our
businesses
i will not sacrifice tens of millions of
jobs
thousands and thousands of companies
because of
the paris accord it was so unfair china
doesn't kick
in until 2030. russia goes back to a low
standard
and we kicked in right away it would
have been
it would have been it would have
destroyed our businesses so
be ready we have done an incredible job
environmentally
we have the cleanest air the cleanest
water and the best carbon emission
standards
that we've seen in many many years vice
president destroyed our general
agreement where other countries
benefited
president biden two minutes to you
uninterrupted
climate change climate warming global
warming is the next essential threat to
humanity
we don't have much time we're going to
pass the point of no return
within the next eight to ten years again
four more years of this man okay
eliminating remember when cassio cortez
said it's like 12 years we won't have a
world right right and then everyone said
she really believes that she said i was
obviously joking he just said eight to
ten years
he shortened the time frame
he's [ __ ] crazier than aoc
people worried about jobs to support my
climate plan
because what it does it will create
millions of new
good-paying jobs we're going to invest
in for example
five hundred thousand fifty thousand
fifty thousand
charging stations big differences so
that we can own the electric car market
of the future
in the meantime china is
and retrofit them so they don't leak as
much energy saving
hundreds of millions of barrels of oil
in the process
and creating significant number of jobs
and by the way the whole idea of what
this is all going to do it's going to
create
millions of jobs and it's going to clean
the environment our health
and our jobs are at stake that's what's
happening and what right now by the way
wall street firms indicated that my plan
you undertake
my my plan will in fact create 18.6
million jobs
seven million more than his this is from
wall street and
i'll create one trillion dollars more in
economic growth
than his proposal does not on climate
just on the economy
president trump you're right came out
and said very strongly
six thousand five hundred dollars will
be taken away from families under
his plan that his plan is an economic
disaster
if you look at what he wants to do you
know if you look at his plan
his environmental plan you know who
developed it aoc
plus three they know nothing about the
timing
i mean she's got a good line of stuff
but she knows nothing about the climate
and they're all hopping through hoops
for aoc plus
doing good yeah yeah they're real
playing
trillion dollars
because i want to make bigger windows
into smaller windows
as far as they're concerned if you had
no window it would be a lovely thing
this is the craziest plan that anybody
has ever seen
and this wasn't done by smart people
this wasn't done by
anybody frankly i don't even know how to
be good politically
they want to spend a hundred trillion
dollars
it's a real number he's trying to say it
was six it's a hundred trillion dollars
they want to knock down buildings and
build new buildings with little
tiny desire of disbelief
so let's hear from the vice president i
have a number more questions i don't
know where he comes from
i don't know where he comes up with
these numbers when 100 let's go
ahead let's go with scranton can't
answer the questions yet yeah this
plan was this is planned endorsed by
every major
every major environmental group and
every labor group
labor because they know the future lies
can we back there's no way that's not
and by the way the fastest growing
industry in america
are is is is the electric that's the uh
uh solar energy and wind he thinks now
causes
cancer no windmills it's the fastest
growing jobs
and they pay good prevailing wages right
45 50 bucks an hour
by the way worse for the environment
take a look at germany versus france
also when you're talking about solar
how do you mine those materials joe how
do you store the energy we don't have
the batteries
to store a city's infrastructure as far
as the energy infrastructure for a city
individuals can do it everything you
just said is a lot i know more about
wind than you do it's extremely
expensive
kills all the birds there you go the
union's not endorsing the green new deal
kristen welker both germany and china
and the fumes coming up if you're a
believer in carbon emission
the fumes coming up to make make these
massive windmills
is more than anything that we're talking
about with natural gas which is very
clean one other thing
find me some solar system i love solar
but solar doesn't quite have it yet
it's not powerful yet to to really run
our big
beautiful factories that we need to
compete with the world
so far it's all a pipe dream incorrect
you know what we'll do
we're going to have the greatest economy
in the world but if you want to kill the
economy
get rid of your oil industry you want
and and what about fracking all right
now let me now let me have it let me
allow vice president
to respond never said i oppose frackie
you said on tape i didn't we'll show the
table put
he said he was gonna ban fracking that's
a lie kristen welker
unless you're real unless you're
[ __ ] sweetheart you know that's a
lie
if you're following up with donald trump
on two three four questions in
as far as we led with which
pharmaceutical companies specifically
are going to give us a vaccine before
the election
then you should ask him hey wait hold on
a second joe you did say you would ban
fracking we will show you the clip
in our post game wrap up after this it's
clear as day he basically says
i'll ban fracking i have one more
question in this position
he was against franklin he said it i
will show that to you tomorrow
i am against fracking until he got
denomination went to pennsylvania then
he said
but you know what pennsylvania he'll be
against it very soon because his party
is totally against fracking on federal
land i said no
fracking
it's fracking that requires any kind of
a trajectory any kind of a pipe
to even broach federal land at any point
which by the way is necessary for any
fracking to work which is what makes it
so clean energy efficient and better
than bringing in oil on tankers from
saudi arabia you dumb [ __ ]
another four years in office the
families that we're talking about are
employed heavily and they're making a
lot of money more money than they've
ever made
if you look at the kind of numbers that
we produce for hispanic
okay we're black or asian it's nine
times
greater the percentage gain than it was
under in three years
than it was under eight years of the
two of them to put it nicely nine times
more
somebody lives i have not heard the
numbers or the statistics
really but they're making a tremendous
amount of money
to put it nicely we saved it and your
mom is a drug addict
oil was crashing because of the pandemic
we saved it
we got to say what you want about
relationship we got saudi arabia
mexico and russia to cut back way back
we saved our oil industry
and now it's very vibrant together and
everybody has very inexpensive gasoline
ready president bryden
your response and then two dollars
plants that in fact pollute chemical
plants and oil plants and refineries the
pollutant
i used to live near that when i was
growing up in clemont delaware
and all refineries and markets look in
the delaware river than there is
any place including in houston at the
time when my mom get in the car
and when when their first frost when
they drive me to school
oil slick in the window that's why so
many people in my state were dying
and getting killed it's gonna be
starting to surfactant
time zone joe that was 70
years ago maybe something more recent
that
the pollutants coming out of those fence
line communities
okay i have one final close down
would you close down there by the way i
would transition from the oil industry
yes
oh transition it is a big statement
because i would stop why would you do
that because
why would you do that significantly i
said here's the deal but that's a big
step
well if you let me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
gas and should shoot me to the
oh what a big man you are next time you
can show me how to chew it
oil industry we actually do go to solar
and wind that's maybe
the biggest statement in terms of
business that's the biggest thing okay
because basically what he's saying is he
is going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you
remember that pennsylvania
zero emissions the first place to do
that by the year 2035 is an energy
production
by 2050 totally all right is he going to
get china to do it no we're finished
with it is he going to get china to our
final question
i'm going to rejoin paris accord to make
china abide by what they agreed to all
right
how do you have leverage will you join
in with every other country
you couldn't even get people to pay 0.5
in nato for eight years
0.5 and nato we'll each have
one minute starting with you we have to
make a country
totally successful as it was prior to
the plague coming in from china
now we're repaying it and we're doing
record numbers 11.4 million jobs at a
short period of time etc
but i will tell you go back before the
plague came in just before
i was getting calls from people that
were not
normally people that would call me they
wanted to get together we had the best
black unemployment numbers in the
history of our country
hispanic women asian
people with diplomas with no diplomacy
graduates number one in the class
everybody had the best numbers and you
know what the other side
wanted to get together they wanted to
unify success
is going to bring us together we are on
the road to success
i'm cutting taxes and he wants to raise
everybody's taxes and he wants to put
new regulations on everything
he will kill it if he gets in you will
have a depression the likes of which
you've never seen
your 401ks will go to hell and it'll be
a very very sad day for this country
all right vice president biden same
question to you what will you say
during your inaugural address to
americans who did not vote for you
i will say i'm an american president
i represent all of you whether you voted
for me or against me
and i'm going to make sure that you're
represented i'm going to give you hope
we're going to move we're going to
choose science
over fiction we're going to choose hope
over fear we're going to choose to move
forward because we have enormous
opportunities enormous opportunities to
make things better
we can grow this economy we can deal
with the systemic racism and at the same
time
we can make sure that our economy is
being
run and moved and motivated by clean
energy
creating millions of new jobs and that's
the fact
that's what we're going to do his
closing speech is about energy because
it's the last question
yeah he can't think of anything that
happened before that no
this isn't a general closing statement
it's about the last question
making sure that everyone has an even
chance and i'm going to make sure you
get that
you haven't been getting in the last
four years all right
i want to thank you both for a very fast
hour and a half a fantastic debate
really appreciate it president trump
former vice president joe biden
thank you to belmont university for
hosting us tonight and most importantly
thank you to those watching tonight
election day is november 3rd
don't forget to vote thank you everyone
and have a great night
[Music]
okay again the uh there you have it the
promo code is
crowder mania that's where you get
thirty dollars off right now thirty
dollars off if you go to lottery.com
mug club we're about to go to uh mug
club exclusively for your chat
and the winner of the costume contest
that's only for 24 hours and then we
will have a 30
off discount for the entire election
live stream we'll be live streaming
until we call the election that could so
we could be here for two weeks oh wow
you never know so please do tune in for
that i need to
uh and uh we will be taking a chat
exclusively uh i want to do we have the
fracking clip from joe biden
can you guys let me do we have that yes
before we do anything else i want to
show you this because this is something
where he just lied and he was not fact
checked at all and we'll give you our
closing thoughts
let's bring up the joe did joe biden
ever say
imply or insinuate that he would ban
fracking
no more no new fracking we are
we are going to get rid of fossil fuels
like what about say stopping cracking
and stopping would there be any place
for fossil fuels
including coal and fracking in a biden
administration
no it would be we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
i
no ability for the oil industry to
continue to drill
period ends number one three consecutive
american presidents have enjoyed
stints of explosive economic growth due
to a boom in oil and natural gas
production
as president would you be willing to
sacrifice some of that growth
even knowing potentially that it could
displace thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands
of blue-collar workers in the interest
of transitioning to that greener economy
the answer is yes the answer is yes
no more no no fracking that's lupine wow
wow so listen a couple of things to note
and this bothers me both about the right
and the left unless something is blatant
then people don't have something to
[ __ ] about
this to me was far worse than chris
wallace
far worse than chris wallace because of
how subversive it was
because of the one two three four
specific
follow-ups on donald trump and none on
joe biden
you have to believe one of two things i
keep wanting to say savannah
you have to believe that kristen welker
either doesn't know about
any of those quotes what was that at
least half a dozen from joe biden either
doesn't know in which case she's totally
unqualified to be a journalist
moderating the debates
or she's lying there is no in between
yeah
there is no in between you cannot
justifiably say
well i need to fact check president
donald trump when donald trump says
we have vaccines coming down the
pipeline we're making a lot of progress
that's not something that you need to
necessarily fact check that's providing
people hope and then you go
when before election when which
companies can you name the companies
will you give us specifics
whereas joe biden says i've never said
that i've never said i'll ban fracking
that's a specific and it's one that if
you are qualified to do your job you
hang him on this was worse because just
like i say governor whitmer is far worse
than
aoc far worse than what's the name of
somalian pirate uh uh
ilan omar rashida same kind of ideology
this is my this is my house now your
congress belongs to me
this is she's a different coat of paint
governor with the same policies
that's what you have with kristen welker
she is just as bad she's far worse than
chris wallace
she didn't follow up at all on joe biden
do you honestly believe that she doesn't
understand that joe biden is lying about
fracking something else that i think is
pretty important
donald trump in closing made a great
statement and i don't think he realized
just how wide-reaching it was where he
talked about okay minorities are doing
better than ever before we're actually
reducing carbon emissions we're actually
improving
green energy all of which is true by the
way here let me let me fact check this
for you
yes black unemployment is at record low
yes
more people are driving electric cars
and moving to green energy than ever
before
yes we have reduced our carbon emissions
more than we ever have in the united
states
yes gas is also cheaper at the same time
because we've made
our own natural resources gas oil more
accessible
rather than being dependent on foreign
sources which by the way is also why
carbon emissions are overall
lower all of those things are true but
here's what's important
donald trump managed to accomplish all
of those things and by that i mean the
conservative ideology without going out
and saying
hey we're going to subsidize solyndra
without going out and saying
hey we're going to give you more food
stamps with which joe biden
basically said tonight with with black
people without going out and saying
hey we're going to give you a free
citizenship by the way if you want to
talk about value added a united states
citizenship is the most valuable piece
of paper you can have
the world over without any of those a
rising tide
lifts all ships and what has donald
trump done all of those things that he
said were true
but if you look at specific policies did
he say we're going to punish the oil and
gas industry no he didn't did he say
we're going to punish white people so
that black people have more employment
no he didn't did he say we're going to
punish working-class
americans so that we can create more
passive citizenship no he didn't
what he did was stepped out of the way
reduced regulation reduced taxes
and that benefited everybody because
business owners were able to step
in and do their job and employ more
americans and create the greatest
economy that we've ever known and i'll
tell you this i'll tell you what
if joe biden becomes president there are
a lot of companies out there who will
have to lay people off yeah
we won't i'm just going to take a pay
cut myself just so you know we might we
might not grow as much
we might not be able to do as many shows
because we may not have as much money
for production but i'm not going to be
laying anybody off but i can tell you
that there will be a direct impact on
this company right now
louder with crowder if joe biden becomes
president and his economic policy
becomes law
take two salaries audio wave you can
show audio weight
okay audio weighed or it could be token
one
or it could be quarter black garrett
take two
full salaries at minimum is what we will
see in an increase in taxes and i'm
making you a promise that we're not
going to lay people off because of that
but we may have to scale back on
production
there is a direct impact from economic
policy
and the same can be said for energy the
same can be said for black people
how do you think elon musk went to texas
does texas have more pro-green subsidies
than california
no texas just has a non-crippling
statist economy when compared to
california
so elon musk the man who thinks of this
world
could be mad and max in a very short
period of time
and a man who by every box that you
check should be a liberal
left california the economy that banned
how many
suvs car lots could have to encourage
the green
car electric car industry he's leaving
them for the
texas oil man state that should tell you
what you need to know
create an economy that benefits
everybody
and a rising tide lifts all ships and
donald trump
oh my gosh what a positive message a
message of hope
a message of what america is and what
america can be and he has the stats to
back
it up joe biden doesn't want to fall
back on his record
his record is racial jungle and the 94
crime bill and forgetting where he is
when he drinks a bucket of salt water
someone turns on the microwave so he has
to make a bunch of empty promises that
christian walker will never
fact-check him on this was a very stark
contrast
i think it was a surprising win for
donald trump and i said going in that it
may be a silver lining
the fact that they have two minutes when
you look at joe biden
joe biden was not able to handle two
minutes by himself
he does not do well with alone time he
does not do well without a backup band
and as much as kristen walker was trying
to be the backup band
it didn't work final thing i will say is
there was a recent fight in the ufc
actually one of the only organizations
that has seen actually a record increase
in viewership because they allow people
to express their own political views and
they don't put a black lives matter in
the middle of their octagon
there's a recent fight brian ortega
fought in the ufc he fought against a
guy named korean zombie now for those
who don't watch fighting just listen and
i'll make sure that this makes sense to
you
brian ortega had been out of fighting
for i believe it was a year and a half
or two years
his last fight he lost a title fight and
he lost pretty badly and people said
well you know what that may be the end
for him
after that fight brian ortega switched
camps he fired a lot of his people the
only person that he kept was henry
gracie a good
good friend of the show part of the
grace gracie family and the question was
it's been a long layoff as their ring
rust how will brian ortega come back
brian ortega came back watched the fight
from last weekend and it was
possibly the most masterful performance
we've ever seen
in the 145 division in the ufc because
he listened to the feedback
he listened to the criticism he
recalibrated and he came back as a whole
new fighter
donald trump tonight was the brian
ortega of politics
this was a new man who came back he
corrected course it's it's a repeat of
the second debate with hillary clinton
and i only wish that we would have a
third but joe biden has to get back to
his basement
what do you think uh their macho man
randy i i definitely think you're right
i think this was a different candidate
this time
for you know getting re-elected um and
he did a great job he held back when he
needed to he
he fought really hard and he gave joe
biden enough rope to hang himself you
and i were talking about whether he
would actually make that correction
between the debates we're like i hope
somebody's in his ear i hope somebody is
going to make him listen and thank god
that he did
the the messages there was a stark
contrast right it was
dark winter for joe biden that's what he
said we're heading into a dark winter
donald trump said
things are getting better the economy is
getting better jobs are getting better
it was a positive message for the
country and joe biden said
things are horrible you need me to come
in and save you and donald trump is like
okay what's your policy to save
well we're we're going to get rid of
your tax plan okay we're going to keep
the economy closed oh really so you want
to take
tax dollars that we don't have to give
to people that would do better if they
don't remember simply you weren't here
he critiques donald trump on tax dollars
when donald trump was talking about how
i was paid for by china by the
terrorists well no i saw that i
was here for that i got 800 billion
dollars so it's totally inconsistent
it's totally inconsistent he doesn't
have a plan like he keeps coming out and
saying we need to give them money we
need to give them money
no you don't listen open the economy
you idiot you don't need to give them
any more money you need to open the
economy and let the american people do
what we do best and that is go out
and be entrepreneurs and innovate and
create jobs well listen get out of our
way i want to go to quarterback garrett
audio wade's thoughts we're going
to read the costume winner at
louderwithcrowder.com as well as all of
your chats after this
but i will say this you know you've
heard me say this before what was the
message tonight
listen if republicans are the party of
the rich meaning and
i don't know what that means anymore
because the rich meaning big tech big
hollywood big wall street big banks they
all endorse joe biden
but republicans certainly are the party
of business owners republicans are
certainly the party
of people with more money in their
pockets or who want more money in their
pockets
if republicans are the party of the
business minded if republicans are the
party of the upper middle class which
statistically they vote overwhelmingly
that's a big myth too
the ultra wealthy the bill gates the
mark zuckerbergs of the world
they don't vote republican no but the
small business owners the people who
maybe
do do make four hundred thousand a year
and aren't just holding public office
but have worked their way up and they
manage small businesses and maybe
they're making half a million maybe
they're making a million you shouldn't
vilify them
you shouldn't hate them those people the
people who employ most of you watching
they vote republican so if the
republican party if donald trump is the
party
of the upper middle class wealthy their
incentive to have a voting base
is to keep you wealthy if democrats are
the party of
the uber rich or the poor or blacks on
welfare
as joe biden said welfare i'll make sure
that more of them are on welfare
guess what it's in their best interest
to keep you
on welfare if the republican party what
you heard tonight was a message of
independence look
we have to get the country back open we
have to get back to normal
donald trump was saying we have to get
people back to their work we have to get
people to
to back to running their businesses we
have to get teachers back to teaching
we have to get the economy
self-sustaining once again
if that's his message the only way
donald trump wins
the only way donald trump has a w next
to his name in that column
at the end of his presidency hopefully
eight years is guess what
if americans are self-sustaining joe
biden it was like game of thrones only
the first half winter is coming it's
going to be a dark winter
show us where you mess up the white
walkers which by the way
he looks strikingly like the icy blue
eyes and the hand
and not to mention the demonic soul if
the democrat party is a party of
you can't do it it's a dark winter and
we're going to continue welfare guess
what
it is in their best interest to make it
a dark winter it is in their best
interest to make sure that you need to
stay
on welfare it is as clear as humanly
possible and if people are
listening to what they heard tonight oh
my god i'm so grateful that actually
people often say this about the polls
well you know what actually the swing
state polls
are closer to within the margin of error
than at this point with hillary clinton
versus donald trump
i'm glad to hear that but i expect after
tonight that we're going to see those
tighten up
quite a bit because people from scranton
are going well they can't even say
i know that [ __ ] because they don't
they've never seen him there
he left when he was in a baby carriage
so uh
i think this was overall a pretty good
debate
i think it moved the needle and it'll be
interesting to see how this changes the
campaigning moving forward
and uh i think that this was the most
shameful moderating that we've seen that
include i think this was worth in
savannah guthrie i think it was worse
than chris wallace
and right now we are about to go
exclusive to mud club at lighter
earthquater.com
club the promo code is crowder mania you
get 30
off for the next 24 hours and we'll be
offering that 30
off on election night it only comes
tonight and then once every four years
that discount again the discount code is
crowder mania
it's what allows us to continue because
uh apparently we've already been
demonetized for this tonight
of course naughty language and also cnn
isn't all too happy so
youtube thank you screw you but right
now we're going exclusive
[Laughter]
piss off
you